So Leute, bin ich am Start, ähm, heute probieren wir nochmal Windows XP aus, allerdings auf
echter Hardware.
Ich hab nochmal alles Zeug ausgebuddelt, weil ich hab mir gedacht, das ist cooler,
wenn ich das für das Video auf echter Hardware mach, weil ich muss mal kurz mein Headset
entwirren, weil ich hör mich auf der einen Seite irgendwie nicht richtig, das liegt
meistens daran, dass es nicht richtig eingesteckt ist, da wieder da.
Und soll ich euch mal was sagen, das ist echt wieder mal ein, dass ich das Headset
was ich hier auf hab, ne, das ist echt mal wieder was, wo man sieht, dass sich Qualität
auszahlt.
Ich mein, ich hab mir das gekauft, wann 2011 oder so, ich hab doch sogar ein Video zugemacht
oder?
Hier, guck mal, August, August, August 2012, also sprich, das ist jetzt 8,5 Jahre alt
und ist wunderbar top, ja, schon ein paar Sabot für Hardware-Suche eingesetzt, ja,
der funktioniert, der funktioniert, wie gesagt, ich nehm' den jetzt ja als fast fertiges,
aber Webinterface, dafür gibt's noch nicht, der Eichler, dankeschön, 17 Monate in Folge,
ist ja massive, das ist nicht einfach Subscriber, das ist, wo hab ich's denn, wo ist mal, wo
ist es, ich find' meine Mod nicht mehr, Hyper-Subscriber, aber richtig, IQ++++++, geht das eigentlich?
Kann man eigentlich, in C++ geht das bestimmt, kann man eigentlich sowas machen, kein Ahnung,
bind A gleich 0 und dann A++++++, ich würde vermuten, dass das geht und ich vermute mal,
dass es dann 2 ist, das ist quasi ein Statement, das, also ich vermute das jetzt einfach mal,
das ist ein Statement, kann ich tippen, das ist ein Statement, das ist 1, das ist 1 und
dann von links nach rechts++ und dann plus das, irgendwie so, in C++, das ist in C nicht
gedacht, schon mehr fast, in C++ ist aber unnormal, das heißt, es kann durchaus sein, dass es
funktioniert. So, ihr wollt' Leute, ich muss erstmal mal den Chat hier wieder aufmachen,
dass ich auch richtig was seh'. Exzellent. Aber die Musik ist Poggers, oder? Richtig
gut erzählt, ja, ich hab's ja schon ein paar Mal zum Besten gegeben, aber ich hab' mir
gedacht, ich muss der YouTube auch mal mitbeklücken. Also, der Detlef fragt, ich überlege mir
ein 19 Zoll Server mit Xeon Gold, ich mach' mal kurz die Musik ein Stückchen leiser.
Vorher muss ich mal gucken, ob Teams nicht wieder den Sound verstellt hat. Eigentlich
für den Sub, aber der Kengi, 6 Monate, aja ja. Nein, exzellent, aber Teams weiß man
nie. Also, jetzt immer zur Frage vom Detlef, ich überlege mir ein 19 Zoll Server mit Xeon
Gold, 18 Kerne und 128 Gb ECC-Rahmen zu kaufen. Oh, nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht. Weil der
komplett passiv gekühlt ist und auch unter Volllast laufen können soll, was hältst du
von sowas, meinst du, es kann funktionieren. Also, kommt auf an, wie groß der ist, aber
18 Kerne unter Volllast passiv kühlen, das funktioniert, wenn es in einem Rack steckt,
wo es eine Klimaanlage gibt. Also, wenn es in einem normalen Rechenzentrum eingebaut
ist, wo, äh, quasi Klimatisierung in dem jeweiligen Schrankabteil, Abteilung ist, dann
geht das. Aber, vielleicht, vielleicht, auch wenn es irgendwie super clever konstruiert
ist, dass das alles irgendwie übers Gehäuse ableitet oder so. Ansonsten, pfff, ich würde
mal den Review angucken vorher auf jeden Fall. Doch, doch, ich hab das vor 6 Jahren sicherlich
erzählt. Bestimmt. Ich mein, ich mach den Kram jetzt über 10 Jahre, da hab ich bestimmt
nur die eine oder andere Sachen mehrfach erzählt. Ja, wie gesagt, also Qualität beim Headset
hat sich echt ausgezahlt. Seit 8 Jahren hat schon das MMX300 erste Generation am Start,
was kostet das aktuell? 235 Euro, das ist die aktuelle Variante. Lohnt sich auf jeden
Fall über Lichtdurchspar. In der gleichen Zeit hättet ihr 5 Logitech-Headsets durchgehabt.
Oh, es geht nicht. Es geht auch in C++ nicht, das wundert mich jetzt. In C++ geht fast jeglicher
Scheiß. In C++ geht ja auch Sachen, von denen man erwarten würde, dass was ganz anderes
rauskommt. Du kannst mir einen Link zur Konfiguration schicken, aber nachdem ich halt nicht weiß,
wie das gebaut ist, kann ich da halt nicht wirklich was zu sagen. Ähm, nee, den Gula
im Artikel hab ich nicht gesehen. Ähm, was war denn die Frage hier jetzt? Nee, OZ, nicht
OV. Wo ist er? Da ist er. Ähm, nee, den hab ich nicht gesehen. Die sind ja schon ne ganze
Weile da am Rumwursten, nachdem sie sich jetzt die letzten 5 Jahre gestritten haben, an wem
es liegt. Ob es an X liegt, an den Grafikkartenhersteller liegt, an den Browserhersteller liegt, an
den AP-Zwischen-Schnittstellen-Programmierern liegt, ob es an was auch immer wem liegt,
aber sie sind ja schon seit ner Weile auf dem Weg. Das Problem ist nur, dass das so hinten
dran ist mittlerweile, dass es eigentlich echt nur noch lächerlich ist. Ich weiß, ich find's
gut, dass das jetzt langsam, aber sicher endlich mal kommt, aber kann auch nicht sein, dass
die unter Linux 5 Jahre, 6 Jahre brauchen. Wie gesagt, für Dinger, die halt schon Ewigkeiten
unter anderen Plattformen funktionieren. Als nächstes an die Weihnachts...da gibt's ja
nicht viel zu erzählen, außer dass ich's verschissen hab, ja. Was soll's da groß zu
erzählen geben, ja. Ja, ich kann...wie gesagt, ich kenn die...ich weiß nicht, wie die das
Gehäuse gebaut haben, deswegen weiß ich nicht, das kann ich echt nix zu sagen. Nicht dass
am Ende du sagst, der Max hat gesagt, es geht, Anzeige geht's raus, es geht nicht. Machst
du beruflich, mach mal Ausrufezeichen Beruf, ich hab das irgendwann mal versucht zu erklären.
Ähm, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das da groß erzähl, nix, was soll die großartig sagen.
Mein armer damaliger Arbeitgeber hat eh gesagt, die haben auch...ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich
euch das mal erzählt hab. Wir machen jetzt mal so, ich flash mal nen USB-Stick und in
der Zwischenzeit erzähl ich euch das dann, was mir da echt auf den Sack gegangen ist.
Ich mach mal kurz die VM an, brauch mal hier nen USB-Stick und ich muss Windows XP erstmal
flashen auf den USB-Stick, dann erzähl ich euch was. Also, die Progress-VM an. So. Genau,
also während ich das jetzt mit dem USB-Stick mache, kann man die Windows XP ISO einfach
flashen, ohne dass irgendwas passiert? Hm. Wahrscheinlich. Sonst kann man ja einfach
die Ideen auf irgendeinen USB-Stick...kann bestimmt einfach nur USB-Stick-Ideen und
so gut ist hier. Oh, ich hab keinen Platz mehr. Ich hab keinen USB-Platz mehr. Wartet mal,
was zieh ich denn jetzt raus? Die externe Festplatte kann ich rausziehen, die brauchen
wir grad nicht. Ja. Connect to Virtual Machine. Exquisite. Wie groß ist das Ganze? 1,1G, das
sollte passen, weil ich hab hier nen USB-Stick dran. Mit sagenhaften...mit sagenhaften...3,81G.
Exzellent, exzellent. Okay. Also, ich mach mal das ISO auf den USB-Stick. Wobei kann
man das mit Edger machen? Das geht doch bestimmt mit Edger auch. From file. ISO. Add. Continue.
Das haben wir doch letztens erst geflashed, das hat funktioniert. Moment, Moment, ist
das das Richtige? Doch, das ist das Richtige. Das ist VVVVVVVVVVV, ja? Gucken wir mal, ob
es funktioniert. Wir probieren einfach aus, ob es geht. Wenn nicht, kann ich es mit einem
anderen tun. Also, ich wollte euch ja erzählen, während das flasht. Oh, massive USB-Speed.
Das ist übrigens ein richtiger Drecks-USB-Stick, den ich da hab. Die guten find ich nicht.
Ich hab zwei richtig gute. Schon vor Jahren mal gekauft, aber als USB-Sticks teilweise
man sich auch drauf verlassen konnte. Aber ich weiß nicht, wo ich die hin hab. Echt nicht.
So ein billiger Werbegeschenk-USB-Stick jetzt. Also, genau, was ich euch erzählen wollen,
ist folgendes. Also, während das flasht. Ich hab ja gesagt, mein Arbeitgeber damals
war eh nicht so geil. Wie gesagt, ich hab ja eine Ausbildung gemacht beim Provider und
die hab ich dann auch kurz übernommen nach der Ausbildung und sowas. Und ich bin dann,
übrigens, was heißt auch noch, kurz übernommen. Ich bin ja dann freiwillig weg. Und zwar,
die haben dann ganz merkwürdige Dinge getrieben. Und zwar haben die gesagt, oh ja, cool, wir
starten ein Fortbildungsprogramm. Fängt der Provider mit T an. Nee, das war nicht die
Telekom. Das war was kleineres. So, und die haben gesagt, wir starten jetzt so ein Fortbildungsprogramm,
weil das so die Zeit war, wo die Leute alle gemeckert haben, so nach dem Motto, Alter,
ihr bezahlt ja kaum was und Weiterbildung wird nicht bezahlt und sonst was in der Richtung.
Dann haben die gesagt, okay, ich muss jetzt gucken, dass ich das halbwegs richtig wiedergebe,
schon eine ganze Weile her. Und dann haben die gesagt, ja, wir machen jetzt das große
Fortbildungsoffensive. Da bin ich schon, wie ich sag mal, nicht schwerhörig, da bin ich
schon skeptisch geworden. Wenn die mit solchen Wörtern um sich geschmissen haben, die große
Fortbildungsoffensive wird gestartet. Und wisst ihr worauf das dann rausgelaufen ist
am Ende? Du wusstest, es ist nicht etwa so stutzig, hellhörig, hellhörig, genau. Und
die haben dann gesagt, nicht, du darfst dir die Schulungen raussuchen, die du machen
willst. Nein, der Arbeitgeber sucht für dich die Schulungen raus. Und die haben mir fünf
Schulungen rausgesucht, die absolut, vollkommen bescheuert waren. Ich krieg diese fünf Schulungen
nicht mehr zusammen. Die haben mir einmal rausgesucht, irgendeine Cisco 1 und 2 Schulung,
das wäre noch ganz okay gewesen. IBM Host, haben die mir rausgesucht. Host, der hätte
ich wahrscheinlich wirklich Kobold gelernt. Und noch irgendwie ein Linux Ding oder so.
Es war zum größten Teil total bescheuert. Also die haben mir, ohne Scheiß, die haben
mir eine IBM Host Schulung rausgesucht. Und der Witz war, die haben das für ein Jahr geplant.
Überlegt euch mal, fünf Schulungen, du musstest natürlich auch dann die Prüfung und sowas
bestehen innerhalb von einem Jahr. So, und jetzt kommts, und jetzt kommts. Dein Vertrag,
also die Erhöhung des Geldes in deinem Vertrag war da dran geknüpft, dass du die Prüfung
schaffst. Das heißt, die haben quasi gehofft, du schaffst sie nicht. Deswegen haben wir
auch so viel rausgesucht, dass du die Prüfung schaffst. Gleichermaßen hat sich dein Vertrag
um... Moment. Ich muss rüber zu meinem Emote. Gleichermaßen musstest du unterschreiben,
dass du glaube ich innerhalb von 5 Jahren... Du hast dich quasi verpflichtet nicht zu kündigen
innerhalb von 5 Jahre. Das ist ja noch schlimmer als dein Machinima Vertrag. Ich weiß gar
nicht, ob das rechtlich überhaupt in Ordnung ist. Wahrscheinlich ist das rechtlich überhaupt
nicht haltbar, was die Typen sich da überlegt haben. So, und das ist ja noch nicht alles
gewesen. Es geht ja noch besser. Und dazu kam, dass du diese Schulungen in deiner Freizeit
machen solltest. Weil es kann ja nicht sein, dass du quasi, wenn dir die Firma das schon
bezahlt, dass du dann quasi der Firma gleichzeitig noch Arbeitszeit kostest. Und wenn du das
nicht... Pass mal auf, die Logik war ja, wenn du das nicht in deiner Freizeit machst, dann
sammelst du Negativstunden, die du woanders wieder abarbeiten musst und sowas. Im Prinzip
du hast es in deiner Freizeit gemacht. Das unterschreibe ich nicht. Das unterschreibe
ich nicht. Kannste vergessen. Das unterschreibe ich nicht. Ich glaube, es geht los, Alter.
Die haben echt den Arsch offen gehabt. Wirklich. Also im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes zu viel
Gatschi Bass bei denen am Start wahrscheinlich. Ja. Wie groß war denn die Kündigungswelle?
Also ich kann dir sagen, dass bei uns in Frankfurt alle gekündigt haben. Alle. Es ist keiner
da geblieben. Es waren acht Leute oder so. Alle. Alle. Ohne Scheiß alle. Alle acht Leute
oder was? Ja, waren alle. Lief. Kick-Bun. Ja, aber das ist doch echt auch voll der Witz,
oder? Das kann nicht in Ernst sein. So. Mal kurz die anderen Fragen schnell aus dem Chat
beantworten. Silent Max hat schon mal guter Domain Name. Nein, ich habe nicht gekündigt.
Ich habe erzählt, als ich damals den Arbeitgeber gewechselt habe, weil mein damaliger Arbeitgeber
komische Dinger getrieben hat. So. Ja, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht wie die... Moment.
Das ist doch nur... Das ist das gleiche Gehäuse, was ich auch habe. Das ist das Genpro Gehäuse.
Das ist das gleiche Gehäuse, was ich auch habe. Guck mal. Das ist das gleiche Gehäuse,
was ich auch habe. Also das Gehäuse ist jetzt nicht der Wahnsinn, was Wärmeableitung angeht,
oder? Das hier. Also das rein passiv gekühlt, stelle ich mir echt sportlich vor. Ich meine,
unhörbar bei voller Leistung ist das kein Problem. Wenn du in das Gehäuse keinen Lüfter
einbaust, ist es halt einfach silent. Aber das ist kein silent Gehäuse. Das ist einfach
silent, weil man in das Gehäuse keinen Lüfter einbaut, obwohl da eigentlich Lüfter reingehören.
Wie viel Hardwarekram hast du mittlerweile rumliegen, für den du keine Verwendung hast?
Oh, zu viel, als ich das jetzt aufzählen könnte. Ufos, das probiere ich danach aus.
Ja, habe ich noch ab und zu. Hast du Tipps programmieren lernen? Schreibe im Februar
meine erste Uni Klausur in Java. Ja, solltest du nicht eigentlich schon programmieren gelernt
haben dann? Ich meine ja nur. Oliver, Twitch Prime, Dankeschön für den Sub. IQ plus plus
für den Chat wieder. So, also schnell mal durch scrollsorn. Da muss ich mal andere Musik
anmachen, das reicht jetzt. Ja gut, das ist wie bei meiner Abschlussprüfung, da habe
ich das ja auch gemacht. Ist das der neue PokChamp? Ah ne, ich habe gedacht, das ist
der neue PokChamp von heute. Leute, wie ist der neue PokChamp von heute? PokChamp. Immer
noch, immer noch der gleiche. Da haben wir gestern auch schon. Nö, nö. Das sei denn,
du brauchst, willst direkt danach was Neues suchen vielleicht. Kixchamp, also laut dem
Patrick ist das on the way. Okay, also wir haben geflasht, dann gucken wir mal, ob das
ganze funktioniert. Successful, bla bla, ich mache den USB Stick mal ab. Und nu, machen
wir mal. Moment, bevor ich den USB Stick abziehe, einmal SYNC hinten dran, man weiß ja nie.
Okay, USB Stick ab. Also Leute, ich zeige euch mal die Hardware, auf der wir das ausprobieren.
Zotac, Zbox, ID, das Teil. Und jetzt muss ich mal kurz etwas andere Musik machen. Wobei
der Soundtrack ohne Scheiß, ne? Ich weiß ja nicht, wie es euch geht. Aber ich kann
den Soundtrack, den kann ich ohne Scheiß, den kann ich den ganzen Tag in Loop laufen
lassen. Ich finde den übelst nice. Der ist so, weiß ich so, so happy irgendwie. Dabei
ist das ja einfach nur ein Loop von 6 Minuten. Das ist glaube ich übrigens das Outro Soundtrack.
Das Game heißt so. Das Game heißt so. Wobei der beste, wobei ich immer noch sagen muss,
der beste ist, ja der. Den finde ich so geil. Das ist einer meiner absolut Lieblings Soundtracks
von Games. Den habe ich euch ja auch schon gequält mit. Doom Eternal ist auch nice,
aber Doom Eternal ist ein bisschen zu hektisch jetzt. Kennst du die Supergiant Games? Ich
weiß jetzt nicht, welche das sind, ne. Beste hier. Und wenn der Impossible Games Soundtrack,
der kommt ja auch. Impossible Games ist ja dieses Ding, wo du mit diesem, wo du so durch
navigieren musst. Ach Moment, das meine ich nicht. Das meine ich nicht. Es gab da
noch ein anderes. Ne, Hardest Games gab es da noch irgendwie, wo du so, wo du so durch
navigieren musst durch irgendwie so. Genau. Ja, das ist. Ich mache jetzt hier Monster
Hunter Relaxing. Jawoll. Bisschen entspannter das Ganze. Was muss man als System Informatiker
generell machen, um durch die Prüfung zu kommen? Weiß ich nicht. Ach so, Erfahrungsformatik,
Systemmedikation meinst du. Naja, lernen. Alte Prüfung angucken. Wer hätte das gedacht?
Man muss lernen, um durch eine Prüfung zu kommen. Also es kommt manchmal tatsächlich
vor, dass man nicht alles automatisch instant kann und gerade. Wie jetzt? Can't wait. Das
einfachste, was man machen kann, ist alte Prüfung ausprobieren. Ich war genauso überrascht
wie ihr damals. Das Beste, was man machen kann, ist sich alte Prüfung angucken und
ich würde ja auch gerne mit euch mal eine Abschlussprüfung im Stream machen, aber die
sind ja leider Monka Toss Copyright. Das geht ja nicht. Also genau das Ding habe ich hier
als Hardware am Start. Das ist richtig alter Crap von 2011. Hat einen sagenhaften Dual
Core Celeron mit 2 mal 1,1 Gigahertz, also richtig High Power Ding. 2G DDR3, also richtig
so eine Kiste, mit der man eventuell auch Windows XP noch betrieben hat. Dann eine GT610, das
ist glaube ich Lowest Lowend der damaligen Zeit. 500G Festplatte, das ist keine SSD,
sondern normale Festplatte und ein bisschen gedürnt. Ich habe mir nämlich einen Cam Link
gekauft vor einer Weile schon. Ich habe euch ja im Chat gefragt, ob ich einen Cam Link kaufen
soll, aber eigentlich habe ich mir den Cam Link nur gefragt, weil ich eigentlich gehofft
habe, der Chat sagt, der taugt was, aber der Chat hat gesagt, das taugt nichts, man sollte
sich besser nicht kaufen. Mein Problem ist, ich hatte es schon längst bestellt. Und ich
habe das vorher einfach mal angeschlossen, der Cam Link hat den Computer nicht erkannt
als Input. Deswegen habe ich jetzt meine GameCapture HD rausgeholt und darüber werden wir das jetzt
machen. Wobei, was mache ich denn, warum starte ich die GameCapture Software? Wir können
es doch sicherlich auch hier einplanten, oder? Wir können es einfach hier einplanten, add,
wir machen das anders. Ich starte die GameCapture Software, gucke erstmal, ob der Input überhaupt
ordentlich erkannt wird. So, also USB-Stick habe ich hier, angeschlossen habe ich alles,
immer noch doof, dass man das nicht ausplatten kann, vielleicht sollte ich mal updaten. Oh,
das hängt, Leute. Wait, keck wait. What's new? You have, ok, meiner ist glaube ich 50
Billiarden Dings alt. Wisst ihr was, ich installiere mal das Update, ich hab nix. Install, jawoll,
ne? Braucht man da Admin-Rechte für? Nein. Ne. Ja, install, ok, man braucht Admin-Rechte.
Ok, jetzt kann ich mir das Passwort eingeben, kommt ihr nie drauf. Was für ein Internetvertrag
war mal Unity Media 400 down und 40 up, oder so? Jetzt ist es Vodafone. Auf. Oh, da kommt
schon der Trojaner drauf, ich sehe es genauer. So, also, finish, GameCapture, wo ist es hin?
Ah, das ist die, Leute, jetzt mal ernsthaft, warum ist die Games, warum ist die Windows-Suche
so kacke? Nur zu Nextcloud, ja, Not gedrungen, aber nur das nötigste. Kalender, Kontakte
und ein bisschen Sync. Warum ist mein Desktop so voll? Weil das alles irgendwelche Emotes
die der Chat haben wollte. Das heißt, es ist wie immer der Chat dran schuld und nicht ich.
One Moment, please. Ok, ich schalte die Kiste jetzt mal ein und dann gucken wir uns das an,
ob das funktioniert. No input-Signal, ja klar, ich hab hier auch noch nicht an. Wo hab ich
das Netzteil-Kabel? Hier. Netzteil. Sollte es vielleicht nicht unbedingt auf die Erdschmeißen,
sondern hier mal nebenbei auf den Schreibtisch legen und gucken, ob das jetzt funktioniert.
So. Zack. Rein und Power on. Ok, es geht an, es geht an. Pause-Camp. Oh, es tut was. Was
ist denn das? Was hab ich denn da drauf? Was ist das denn? Was ist denn ein Mac? Hab ich
nicht? Ernsthaft? Kann ich überhaupt noch mal dran erinnern? Ah, ja, doch, doch, doch,
doch, ich kann mich dran erinnern. Das ist das Ding, wo die Grafikkarte nicht ging, wo
ich mal versucht hab. Ja, die Grafikkarte ist voll im Arsch gewesen mit Mac. Passt mal
auf, wenn das gebootet ist. Bissi kaputt. Ja. Einfach Sonnenbrille tragen, ja. Ok,
ich mach mal ein USB-Stick dran und dann booten wir neu und gucken, ob wir ordentlich gebootet
bekommen. Ich stöpsel mal meine Tastatur da dran. Nachher machen wir das mit Maus-Sharing
und so. Ok. Mach mal Fullscreen, jetzt gucken wir mal. Haben wir hier eigentlich ordentlich
Highside-Bar? Ah, yes. Endlich haben sie das eingebaut, dass man nicht immer den ganzen
Müll sich wieder ausschalten. So, ich hab die Tastatur dran. Wie startet man das Ganze
neu? Ach, Moment, ich kann hier gar nicht klicken. Braucht man eine andere Maus, wo
ist die andere Maus? Komm her. Komm her, Maus. Andere Maus. Ja, komm. Auf. Maus. Maus anschließen.
So, Maus ist dran. Exzellent. Aber Maus geht nicht. Oh, doch. Wow. Ach stimmt, ich hab
hier die Grafik. Fuck, das leckt jetzt ja mit der Capture-Card. Ok, Leute, da muss ich jetzt
langsam machen. Da muss ich jetzt langsam machen. Restart. Klick. Ok. So, und jetzt
hämmern wir mal irgendwas. Was, was, was müssen wir jetzt machen? Entfernen. F8. Was wird
es denn sein? F8. Was wird es zum Booten sein? Oh. Easy. Einfach direkt getroffen. Dazu kann
man nur sagen, easy as fuck. So, Boot. Warum ist, was ist das eigentlich für ein ultrahässliches
BIOS? Boot Priorities. Moment, wie sage ich dem jetzt, dass er von USB booten soll? Ok,
dann. Boot Priorities gibt es nicht. Ist nicht, ist nicht drin. Ok, dann probieren wir mal
neu zu starten mit F10 oder so. Boot-Menü. Ich drücke jetzt einfach mal F10. Ich hoffe,
dass es F10 ist. Oder auch nicht. Einfach Black Screen. Auch nice. Oh. Ist, ist die Capture-Card
Software abgeschissen? So hätte ich vielleicht noch nicht updaten sollen. Gibt es da unten
zur Auswahl? Kann ich da nicht sagen, Boot von USB oder sowas? Du musst, glaube ich,
in die Boot-Config. Ok, ja, ok. Ich hämmere nochmal F8 entfernen. F2 ist es? Oh, excellent.
Ich hämmere mal F2. Aber Boot Options Priorities konnte ich nix auswählen. Ok, ich gehe nochmal
in Spears. Er erkennt den USB-Stick schonmal. Er blinkt. Der USB-Stick blinkt. So. Boot.
So, Boot Priorities kann ich nicht auswählen. Guck. Priorities gibt es nicht. Gehe mal in
Spears. Check-Wait. Ja, Secure-Pool ist bestimmt noch. Ist da nix aus. Stimmt. UEFI Boots sollte
ich ausmachen. Weil Windows XP kann bestimmt nicht UEFI Booten, oder? Ok, Fastboot, Quietboot,
Security, ME Update Control, was auch immer. Ok, da kann ich schonmal nix einstellen. So,
wie boot ich denn hier von USB? Das kann ja zu kompliziert sein. Das hätte ich zumindest
gedacht. Da steht Boot Configuration. Ne, Boot Configuration ist ja das, was man hier
unten drunter sieht. Boot Override. Ja, wenn das irgendeiner sieht. Was ist denn die Trap
Response? Ok, das funktioniert schonmal nicht. Powermanage kanns auch nicht sein. Main. Wie
kommt man ins Boot Menü? Boot Override, ne. Boot Override bringt nix. Ja, ja, da stand
Boot Priorities, aber da kannste nix einstellen. Hab ich schon. Was sind denn X-Settings? Ah
ja, wir haben wahnsinnig viel mal advanced. Onboard Device Config. USB Configuration.
Wie ist der Kram überhaupt an? Aha, Legacy Support. Das brauchen wir wahrscheinlich,
dass wir booten können davon. USB 3 Support. Ist mir wurscht. Was solls, T-Vices? Da ist
es doch. Ok, ich starte jetzt einfach nochmal neu. Da steht ja meistens irgendwas da, wenn
man bootet, was es ist. Ok, ich mach jetzt einfach mal Strom aus, Strom an und dann sollt
das funktionieren. F12 haben wir schon. Das ist kein Mac. Das ist kein Mac. Ich glaub,
F12 hab ich schon. Boot Menü? Gibt es da ein Boot Menü? Nein. Lol, da gibt es kein
Boot Menü. Sollte mich rollen. F12, F10. Irgendwas muss es doch sein. Er hat gepiepst.
Ok, ok. Also entfernen ist es nicht. Entfernen ist ins BIOS. Also ich drücke jetzt einfach
F10, F12, F8, F7. Easy. Eins davon war es. Oder er erkennt meinen USB Stick nicht. Ok,
da muss ich den anders booten. Press Enter to select Boot Device. Alles klar. Nice. Dann
hab ich den USB Stick. Was war es denn jetzt? F8, F7? Mal gucken, ob man das reproduzierbar
hinkriegt. Ne, ne, ich hab Legacy, Legacy Boot ist an. Guckt, Legacy Boot ist an. Ja,
Advanced, USB. Oops. Legacy USB Support ist am Start. Ansonsten kann man da nichts großartig
auswählen. Gut, dann werde ich jetzt mal das anders flashen. Dass es nicht das richtig
ausgeht. Mehrere Legacies, alles klar. So, das liegt am USB Stick. Der USB Stick ist
wahrscheinlich nicht richtig gemacht, denke ich mal. Was anderes kann man hier auch gar
nicht großartig ausschalten. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Das funktioniert so nicht. Da kannst
du nichts machen. Oder? Was kann man da auswählen? Ah! Kehrkveh. Schau mal, der Chat hat ja sogar
recht. Wahnsinn. Okay, PXE brauchen wir nicht. Das brauchen wir auch alles nicht. Das ist
kein Mac. Der Chat wieder, Alter. Sieht das aus wie ein Mac Bios. So, Save Changes. Save
Changes und Exit. Jetzt bootforcen wir wieder den, den Bootmenü Key. Der macht, der pieps.
Ah, guck mal da. Easy, nice. Okay, zwei Sachen, die nicht funktionieren. Einmal, das booten
geht jetzt, aber der USB Stick ist nicht richtig gemacht. Okay, das können wir ja fixen. Das
lässt sich ja beheben. Da müssen wir den USB Stick jetzt richtig machen. Das da, ne,
warte mal. Das ist das Teil, ne? Für Windows Geschiss. Oder? Hab ich noch nie gemacht.
Ich Edger oder TD alles. Download. Portable. Portable ist immer gut. Jaja. Oh. So, die,
achso, ich sollte den USB Stick vielleicht doch anschließen, ne? Das wäre nicht verkehrt.
Mal gucken, ob Windows überhaupt Windows erkennt. Kann man, aber sag mal so. Man kann
Windows XP doch von USB überhaupt installieren. Geht das? Kann man Windows XP überhaupt von
USB installieren? Bin mir nicht sicher, ob ich jemals Windows XP von USB installiert
hab, sondern nur von CD. Guck mal, der erkennt das gar nicht. Okay, close. Nochmal neu starten.
Jaja. No label. Excellent. Select. Hab ich mir das hier nicht rüberkopiert? Einfach
starten. Wo hab ich mir denn die Windows, das Windows ISO? Oh, Lord. Da bestimmt noch
ein Desktop. Da ist es. Desktop easy. Ich mach alles auf dem Desktop, sieht man ja. So,
ähm. Hab ich den Kram jetzt wieder geschlossen oder ist das nur off? Also, select. Desktop.
Wo haben wir es? Ah Moment, das ist mein anderer User. Das ist mein anderer User, oder?
Hä? What the hell? But why? Oh. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Okay. Okay. Muss ich das jetzt verstehen, dass das nicht da drin ist? So, egal. DVD.
Also, MBR. Blah. BIOS. Alles klar. Muss man wahrscheinlich nix großartig machen, oder?
Das war der Admin Desktop-Folder. Sehr wundern. Aber egal, das ist richtig. Fallsystem. NTFS
ja was anderes geht nicht. Ach nee, das ist was das ursprüngliche ist, oder? Egal, ich
mach jetzt einfach mal starten und lass den flashen. Jaja. Okay. Heute geträumt, dass
du Face Reveal machst und ich weiß jetzt, wie du aussiehst. Oh je. Da kann ich nix
gegen machen. Hast mich überlistet. Wub League. So, mal gucken, ob der jetzt bootet.
Ansonsten bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, wie man da Windows XP draufkriegt. PXE-Boot mach
ich da jetzt ganz bestimmt nicht. Ich guck mal, während der hier... Macht der überhaupt
noch was gerade? Okay, während der hier gerade Zeug flasht, guck ich nochmal chat. Ich hab
bestimmt massig übersehen. Tested auf einer halben... Ja, ich hab nen Dual Core Celeron.
1,1 Gigahertz. Das Teil hab ich am Start hier. Richtig uralt Zeug. Acht Jahre alte Hardware.
Was hast du bis jetzt gemacht, außer irgendwelche alten Stories, dem Chat erzählt, ein USB-Stick
geflashed, der nicht funktioniert hat und festgestellt, dass das Ding nicht so ohne weiteres
von USB bootet, noch nix. So. Egal, ob ich des Unterlienungs- oder Windows-flashe, solange
das Programm was flasht, checkt, was es macht. Wer hat auch noch DVDs? Oh, ich hab tatsächlich
noch ein paar DVDs, aber ich hab kein DVD-Laufwerk mehr. Also ich kann den Kram gar nicht abspielen,
aber da ist nix wichtiges drauf. Ich hab noch, ich hab noch, das ist fast schon ein Sammlerstück,
ich hab noch GameStar-CD, ne GameStar-CD von 1998 mit Demos drauf. Kennst du Venteu für
den Zapp? Ja. Haha, Apple ist doch doch da, unternehmen von Zoltac. Jetzt kommt alles
raus, ja. Rusty, fünf Monate Dankeschön für den Zapp hab ich übersehen, ich muss grad
immer gucken, während der hier am Flaschen ist. Dauert schon deutlich länger als Unterlienungs,
da ich nix übersehen hab. Also Rusty hier, Massive Prime Subscription, fünf Monate. Huge
Zapp. Ich glaub sonst hab ich nix übersehen. Scroll, Scroll, Scroll. Ja. Wie geht es Chica
äh, der gehts gut. Die Licht, die Licht drüben bei mir auf dem Bett und ich hab einfach meine
Decke über die Katz geschmissen und jetzt liegt sie drunter und pennt. Das macht die
manchmal, die setzt sich dann aufs Bett, das heißt nicht etwa setzt sich bisschen dabei
und streichelt mich, das heißt in der Regel, äh, lasst mich unter die Decke, ich will
da jetzt liegen und pennen. Guck dir mal Venteu an. Venteu, hab ich schon nie gehört. Bruder
ich hab schon nie gehört. Ach doch, das kenn ich. Das ist das, wo du nen Stick machen kannst
mit irgendwie 20 Betriebssystem-Images drauf und so, ne? Doch, doch, das kenn ich. Jaja,
das kenn ich, das kenn ich, klar. Ich konnt das bloß grad nicht zuordnen. Jaja, das kenn
ich. Mit meinem 4GB USB-Stick wird das aber nix. So und wenn ich das installiert hab,
probier ich mal, ob der Cam Link funktioniert. Auch was, weil ich halt mal ausprobieren will.
Der Cam Link hat nicht funktioniert, als ich einfach so angeschlossen hab. Das lag, glaub
ich, daran, weil die Auflösung zu gering war für den Cam Link, da kam damit nicht klar.
Mach mal hinne, was macht das so lang? Was macht das denn da, 3 Stunden? Der hat unter
Linux, hat er das geflashed innerhalb von 3 Minuten. Der macht's richtig. Ja, richtig
bedeutet, es muss langsam gehen. Kennen wir ja alle. Wenn's zu schnell geht, dann ist
das nicht richtig. Ja, gut, während er kopiert, da kann ich euch auch noch ein bisschen was
erzählen. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben? Ich hab von dem geilen Schulungsprogramm von
meinem Ex-Arbeitgeber erzählt, ja. Oh, Amazon hat mir grad ne Benachrichtigung geschickt,
mein Raspberry Pi ist auf dem Weg. Exzellent. So muss, also nicht Amazon, dass das verschickt
wurde halt. Das ist ja nicht so, dass wird's irgend einer bei Amazon da wirklich gesessen
hat, hat gesagt, hallo Max, dein Raspberry Pi ist auf dem Weg. Enter. Was kommt auf
den Pi? Das ist der Ersatz für den Raspberry Pi, den hat Jeff Bezos selbst, genau. Der
Max hat da bestellt, dem schrei ich erstmal persönlich kurz ne Nachricht. Da kommt erstmal
gar nix drauf, das wird der neue Bastel Raspberry Pi, weil den alten, den hab ich ja unten jetzt
stehen als Unify Controller und Kamera Streaming. Necurity Camera Streaming, also sprich, ich
hab gar keinen aktuellen Pi mehr zum basteln. Ich frage mich, wann das erste elektronbasierte
OS kommt, naja, es gibt ja schon Chrome OS, das ist ja nicht so weit weg von, ist ja nicht
so weit weg von, von elektron OS. Ja, exzellent Flashspeed. Machen wir mal zur Entspannung
ne Runde ASCII Aquarium an. Also, was könnt ich euch jetzt mal erzählen während der Flash?
Wie gesagt, von diesem komischen Schulungsprogramm vom Ex-Arbeitgeber hab ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Ähm, da waren noch mehr so Dinger, also die waren eh komisch drauf, ne. Da gab's da noch,
also es hatte schon so einen Grund, warum einfach alle Leute gekündigt haben, die damals
bei uns in Frankfurt waren. Hast du noch Ferien, Max? Ne. Ich hab auch keinen Urlaub mehr,
ich musste letzte Woche schon wieder arbeiten. So, zumindest gab's da noch, wie gesagt,
die haben ganz viele komische Dinger betrieben. Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel, ähm, haben die,
das hab ich erst im Nachhinein kapiert. Wie gesagt, das war ja quasi da, wo ich auch direkt
nach der Ausbildung war. Die haben versucht, die Leute halt einfach, äh, einzuschüchtern
permanent mit irgendwelchen, mit irgendwelchen Aktionen, ja. Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel,
dass ähm, einer bei uns in Frankfurt gesagt hat, er, ähm, keine Ahnung, er hat sich
ein bisschen, er hat sich, ich muss das jetzt gar nicht so genau erzählen, der hatte sich
ein bisschen mit der Geschäftsführung in den Haaren, so. Und, ähm, der hat sich dann
auch nicht sonderlich beliebt gemacht, allerdings hat das insofern, also, sagen wir so, insofern
ganz clever gelöst, dass diejenigen nicht wussten, wer es war. Um es jetzt mal so zu
umschreiben. Also, der hat sich unbeliebt gemacht, hat aber nicht seinen Namen drunter
geschrieben, sondern es war im Prinzip nur klar, es hat irgendjemand aus Frankfurt gemacht,
so. Und anstatt das normal zu handeln, ähm, es war nix Schlimmes, kann ich euch gleich
sagen, es war, es war echt nix, nix Wildes, ähm, er hat im Prinzip nur umschrieben, dass
er halt nicht mit einverstanden ist, wie das grad läuft. Also echt nix Schlimmes. Ja,
anstatt das irgendwie normal zu handeln, haben die halt versucht, die Leute übelst einzuschüchtern,
das ging dann so weit, da wurden alle Leute aus Frankfurt zu Einzelterminen mit dem Chef
einbestellt, in denen er rausfinden wollte, wer, und das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt eins
zu eins Quote vom Chef damals, wer der Redelsführer ist. Da denkst du dir auch, wo zum Teufel
bin ich hier gelandet? Was ist das für ein Laden, Alter? Ich will einfach, ich will
einfach nur meine Arbeit machen, lasst mich mit eurem Scheiß in Ruhe. Das war echt ein
komischer Laden. Also, ich hab's damals nicht so gecheckt, weil das, weil ich da halt neu,
weil ich da die Ausbildung gemacht hab, dann direkt hingegangen bin, ich kannte gar nix
anderes. Das ist auch nicht so, als war ich jetzt schon mal 50, also ich war mittlerweile
jetzt auch nicht mal 50 verschiedene Dinge oder so, aber ich hab das damals nicht so
richtig realisiert, was das für ein Drecksladen ist. Mittlerweile glaube ich halbwegs, halbwegs
schon zumindest. Schon ziemlich weird champ, ja. Richtig hängen geblieben. Richtig hängen
geblieben, ja. Ja, die haben halt wirklich versucht, die Leute einzuschüchtern. Was
auch witzig war, was auch, das hab ich mitgekriegt, da war ich schon nicht mehr dort. Ich hab
mitgekriegt, dass die quasi eine komplette Abteilung woanders abgeworben haben oder versucht
haben, eine komplette Abteilung woanders abzuwerben, weil die halt händeringend Leute gesucht
haben. Es sind halt auch massenhaft Leute weggerannt zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wo dieses
Schulungsprogramm da am Start war, was ich euch gerade erzählt hab. Und die haben halt
komplett alle möglichen Leute abgeworben. Und das wurde mir nur erzählt von einem der
der Arbeit. Also ich, wie gesagt, ich war ja schon lange, ich war ja da bestimmt ein halbes
Jahr oder so nicht mehr da. Und die haben den ehemaligen Teamleiter von dem, von diesem
ganzen Team, was sie woanders abgeworben hatten, der haben sie erzählt, was es alles tolles,
geiles gibt und super und toll und hatten auch schon einen Vertrag aufgesetzt und sonst
was. Und der kam dann halt in die Firma, um seinen neuen Vertrag zu unterschreiben.
Und dem haben sie den Vertrag dann gegeben, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass in diesem Vertrag
auf einmal diese ganzen Dinger drin standen, die uns halt auch dazu gebracht haben, warum
wir weg sind. Das haben die dem vorher natürlich nicht erzählt. Und der muss halt da hingekommen
sein, hat gesagt, okay, weiß, hier, top, er unterschreibt jetzt den Vertrag. Da haben
die dem Vertrag gegeben. Der hat den Vertrag gesehen, hat den durchgelesen, hat gelacht
und ist gegangen. Wurde mir nur, wurde mir nur so berichtet. Wie gesagt, ich war ja da
schon ein halbes Jahr nicht mehr da, aber der hat es richtig gemacht. Der hat es richtig
gemacht. Einfach hingegangen, gesehen, die wollten mich eigentlich verarschen. Karnavoz,
ich weiß nicht. Die waren sich keiner Schuld bewusst. Das muss man dazu sagen. Die waren
sich bis zum Schluss keiner Schuld bewusst, dass das vielleicht nicht so beidseitig ausgewogen
war, diese Vertragsänderung. Die haben wirklich gedacht oder so getan, dass tun sie den Leuten
was Gutes. Wie stellt sich die Firma dann die Arbeitsatmosphäre vor? Nicht gut. Wie
gesagt, das sind Sachen, die habe ich erst später realisiert, das ist, was das für
ein Scheißladen war. Das war auch so ein Laden, der war, die haben versucht halt besonders
cool zu sein und hatten dann freitags abends und so haben die dann auch irgendwie so ein
komisches Spielding gemacht und so was. Die haben dann auch so indirekt Druck auf die
Leute aufgebaut, wenn die da nicht teilgenommen haben und so was. Nach dem Motto, ja dann
bist du ja gar nicht Teil des Teams. Was ein dummes Geschwätz. Die sollen sich mal alle
wieder einkriegen. Ganz im Ernst, wer das nicht akzeptieren kann, dass die Leute auch
noch leben außerhalb der Firma haben, der hat halt echt gelitten. Zarex. Zarex, Battlefield
3 mit dem Chef, das ist da, wo ich jetzt arbeite. Ich rede ja dort, wo ich meine Ausbildung
gemacht habe. Mein Chef, der Battlefield 3 gespielt hat, der ist da, wo ich jetzt bin.
Und damals war der ja auch noch nicht mein Chef, als der Battlefield 3 gespielt hat und
Heli geflogen hat. Ne, der Gamer Alex, da habe ich keine großartige Ahnung. Wenn es
anliegt, ist es mega richtig poggers. Alter Rufus, mach halt mal hinne. Ich muss die Maus
bewegen, dann gehts schneller. Guckt Leute, wenn ich die Maus bewege, seht ihr das? Wie
schnell der jetzt kopiert, nur weil ich die Maus nicht stillstehen lasse im Fenster. Sobald
ich rausgehe, hängts, sobald ich reingehe, gehts wieder raus, rein, guck hier. Rufus
Gajibas. Der Chat ist im Weg. Ja, du verpasst nicht wirklich was, aber ich schiebs mal kurz
raus. Rufus ist mit USB 3 schnell, das mag schon sein, aber der USB Stick ist ein oller
Werbegeschenk USB Stick. Wird es überhaupt gehen mit NTFS als Fallsystem? Ach, bestimmt.
Damals gab es schon NTFS, NTFS gibt es lang. Was anderes konnte man auch gar nicht auswählen.
Nein, nicht der übliche, nicht dieser Standard China USB Stick. Das ist ein Werbegeschenk
USB Stick mit Logo vom Hersteller. USB 5.0 aus China. Also wenn es mal USB 5.0 gibt,
sind die Chinesen die ersten, die das am Start haben. Halt bei irgendeinem Fake Stick. 2
Terabyte USB 5.0 Stick haben die dann. Ja genau, wie gesagt NTFS ist alt, aber die haben ja
immer ein bisschen dran rumgefeilt bei Microsoft. Die wollten doch damals für Windows 8 oder?
Die wollten doch damals ein neues Fallsystem machen. NTFS sollte doch abgelöst werden
durch irgendwas neues. Ich glaube das haben die bis heute nicht hingekriegt. Alter Rufus
mach hinne. Max Einschätzung zur Transformierung von klassischer Hierarchie zu Selbstorgateams.
Ich bin froh wenn ich machen kann was ich will, weil im Endeffekt geguckt wird das was
ordentliches rauskommt und nicht so sehr wie man da hinkommt. Das ist mir persönlich lieber,
aber es gibt genug Leute die haben da keinen Bock drauf. Also wir haben bei uns auf der
Arbeit auch genug Leute die sagen, wenn das nirgendwo steht dann mache ich es nicht so
nach dem Motto. Wie ich soll mich da einloggen und was neu starten? Da habe ich noch keine
Schulung zugekriegt, das kann ich nicht. Haben wir auch genug Leute, also es kommt auf die
Leute an. Leute ich gebe zu es ist Massive High Octane Stream gerade, aber ich kann es
auch nicht beschleunigen den Kram. Warte mal gibt es ein BTFS Treiber für ReactOS? Ja
das macht es auch nicht besser. Wir haben ja mal ReactOS ausprobiert, das hat ja mal
absolut gar nicht funktioniert. Wie hieß denn dieses neue File System Windows? Die haben
noch da irgendwas neues entwickelt. ReFS, genau ReFS meine ich. Das hat nie irgendwie
großartig Fahrt aufgenommen. Verwende doch keiner. Ah Max Volumes heißt eine Yobi Byte,
wie viel ist eine Yobi Byte? Viel. Was sagst du zu den neuen Max? Ich kann da ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht so viel dazu sagen. Ich habe mich erstens nicht da großartig mit beschäftigt,
zweitens habe ich mir auch überhaupt keine Benchmarks und sonst was angeguckt und drittens
bin ich jetzt kein großartiger Spezialist was CPU Architektur angeht. Ich finde es auf
jeden Fall eine sinnige Entscheidung aus Apples Sicht. Apple ist davon ein bisschen unabhängiger.
Ja Apple ist dementsprechend von Intel ein bisschen unabhängiger und vor allem Apple
hat ja den großen Vorteil, dass sie jetzt schon Hardware und Software mehr oder weniger
halt nur ganz wenig Auswahl haben und wenn sie noch eine eigene CPU haben, können sie
das noch besser anpassen. Das kann ich schon verstehen. Eine Sache wird aber definitiv
nicht passieren, das war nämlich auch eine Frage, die öfters gekommen ist schon in Streams,
so nach dem Motto, welche Hersteller werden das Apple nachmachen? Ich kann euch sagen,
so gut wie keine, wenn überhaupt irgendwer, weil den Leuten schlicht und ergreifend das
Know How fehlt sowas zu machen. Es kann nicht irgendeine 0-15 Hersteller auf die Idee kommen
und sagen, wir machen mal kurz unsere eigene CPU. Ich weiß, dass es nicht wirklich eine
komplett eigene CPU ist, aber du brauchst schon Leute, die sich damit auskennen und
das macht halt, das kann keiner. Es gibt eine Handvoll Leute auf der Welt, die du da, okay
sagen wir mal zwei Handvoll Leute auf der Welt vielleicht, die du da irgendwie für
gewinnen könntest, die dir dabei helfen. Also da gibt es nicht so viele, mit denen
du sowas aufziehen könntest und das wird kaum einer machen. Residenz-Lieferufus, alter,
wenn das jetzt nicht geht, mache ich Range Quit den Stream aus. Microsoft wird es versuchen,
da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ob Microsoft das versuchen wird. Windows und x86 ist schon
ziemlich eng verheiratet. Ich weiß, dass es einen armen Windows gibt, wo kaum was drauf
läuft. Ich glaube nicht, dass Microsoft das probieren wird. Was, Win Setup from USB?
Wie, Rufus kann das gar nicht, heißt ich mache das jetzt umsonst? Äh, das geht. Ey,
wenn ich das jetzt umsonst mache, mache ich Instant Range Quit. Dann mache ich aus, dann
nehme ich, dann nehme ich das Video in der VM auf, ist mir egal. Bankerautomaten haben
doch noch Windows XP paar, also die RMV, die RMV Ticket-Automaten, die haben den Raspberry
Pi drinne. Ich weiß nicht, ob es hier ein schönes Bild von gibt. Hat der hier vielleicht
ein Bild von gemacht? Ja. Guckt, das habe ich auch mal morgens bei uns am Bahnhof gesehen,
wie die Dinger im Bootscreen hängen. Der Rüpel, 13 Monate. Sf-Subscription, das ist
ja schon Hyper-Subscriber. Äh, beim Rewe, ja, beim Rewe haben die noch alles Zeug
drauf. Beim Rewe hatten die auch letztens eine Config-Excel auf dem Desktop. Da, da
hing ein Monitor im Rewe und auf dem Desktop war Config, Config-Excel. Ich wusste noch
gar nicht, dass man Configs in Excel verteilt. Alter Rufus, gib alles, ey, wir sitzen jetzt
schon 15 Minuten vorneweg und der Kram flasht mein USB-Stick. Nein, keine Idee, warum das
in VirtualBox nicht bootet, kein Plan. Wir haben das ja mal im Stream gemacht, das war
so ein fertiges Installer-Skip, das hat funktioniert. Hätte es nicht funktioniert, hätte ich keine
Ahnung gehabt, wie man das debuggen soll. Kein PXE. Sheet95, das weiß ich nicht, ich
hab das nur am, das kann auch eine CSV sein. Ich hab halt nur gesehen, dass das Excel-Symbol
drauf hatte. Wie gesagt, also ich glaube nicht, dass Microsoft das probieren wird, eigene
CPUs zu machen. Wozu? Microsoft hat ja auch keine eigene Hardware in dem Sinn, die haben
Surface, okay, aber die meisten Sachen für Windows sind ja Custom-Bills. Bei Apple macht
das Sinn. Also bei Apple ergibt es Sinn, die verkaufen ja jetzt schon eigene Hardware mit
eigener Software, da kann man auch eigene CPU reinmachen. Aber wie soll denn Microsoft
das machen? Microsoft muss auf der einen Seite quasi 99,9% der Rechnerkonfiguration supporten
und warum sollten sie dann auch, wenn sie nicht mal eigene Hardware haben, eine eigene
CPU rausbauen? Das ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn. Windows Phone, ja gut, Windows Phone
ist ja vorbei. Silverlight, Silverlight, genau. Gibt es in Silverlight, Wahnsinn, bringen
Silverlight-Box. Silverlight wird wiederbelebt. Jetzt wo Flash tot ist, gibt es keine Konkurrenz
mehr. Auf geht's, Silverlight. Ja, für Surface, nur für Surface eine eigene CPU bauen, das
wäre, glaube ich, auch Microsoft zu doof. Kennst du noch Mixer? Na klar, jeder von uns
kennt noch Mixer. Wo kommt man eigentlich raus? Mixer.com, wo kommt man da jetzt eigentlich
raus? Wie viel gucken das eigentlich so? Ich wills gar nicht wissen. Facebook Gaming,
da haben die bestimmt ein bisschen was für bezahlt, dass die auf Facebook Gaming redirecten.
Wufus, come on, mach hin. Alter, was ist das denn? Ich krieg Anfälle, wie lahm das ist.
73,9, mach halt jetzt. Der hat grad was mit Sony kopiert. PS6 confirmed. Ist das jetzt
schon TOS? Nö, warum? Oder vielleicht, keine Ahnung. Kennst du schon Windows 95 Mobile?
Das Video hab ich gesehen, das kommt mir bekannt vor. Hat Facebook Gaming Mixer gekauft? Nee,
oder? Mixer hat dicht gemacht und die haben gesagt, sie sollen jetzt auf Facebook, nee,
ich glaub nicht, dass die den Rest gekauft haben. Sind die Russen schon in Windows XP?
Ja, in welchen Windows XP denn? Du meinst, die werden mitgeflasht, klar. Oh guck mal,
jetzt gibt der Gas, jetzt gibt der Gas. Kurzzeitig mal, kurzzeitig. Warum ist Wufus denn so krass
langsam? Ich mein, das Ding unter Linux hat geflasht in zwei Minuten, was macht der denn
da? Und wenn das Flaschen so lang dauert, wie lang dauert denn der Install erst? Egal
Leute, ich hab Zeit, ich hab Zeit. Ich war auch schon vorher auf dem Klo, ich hab Zeit.
Flashchamp. Ich würd es nicht Champ nennen. Eher das Gegenteil von Champ. Was ist das
Gegenteil von Champ? FlashPain. Ja, genau. FlashNoop. Nee, FlashNoop war ja schnell.
Vielleicht hätte ich besser über TuneUp 2007 flashen sollen. Massive. Wann kommt
dein OnlyFans? Ih, hast du noch nicht subscribt? Was heißt, wann kommt, der ist schon längst
da. Das haben wir noch nicht alle mitgekriegt. Link, ja, den haben nur Eingeweihte. Chat,
ich seh, ich könnt wetten, aus dem Chat sind da ein paar schon. Danke Tarantel abonniert
Twitch Prime, danke schön für den Sub. Vielleicht gibt's ja nächstes auch noch was zu sehen
im Stream, wenn das Ding mal fertig geflasht hat. Den Link bekommst du nur, wenn du vorher
Patreon gesubbt hast. Und Prime Sub. Übrigens, wisst ihr was ich heute aufgenommen hab, aber
ich weiß nicht, ob ich das veröffentlichen soll, aber wisst ihr was ich heute aufgenommen
hab? Nur weil der Chat das haben wollte. Nur weil der Chat danach gefragt hat. Allerdings,
ich hab halt einfach nur 8 Minuten sinnloses Zeugs gelabert, glaub ich. Ich weiß nicht,
ob ich das wirklich als Video hochlade. Das ist halt, das ist genau so dumm wie das erste
Video. 8 Minuten und nix gesagt, so richtig. Aber ich werd's vielleicht, ich zeig's dir
im Stream. Ich muss noch mal gucken, ob man nicht irgendwelche Leute sieht, weil hinter
mir ist irgendeiner, ist irgendwie ein Opa mit Enkel oder so spazieren gegangen. Und
ich glaub, die hab ich kurzzeitig in der Aufnahme drauf, weil ich die Kamera geschwenkt hab,
das muss ich noch rausschneiden. Ich mein, die Schweizer und Österreicher unter uns
lachen sich kaputt, wenn ich sag, dass das Schnee ist. Die sagen, das ist vielleicht
bisschen gefroren oder so, aber das ist doch kein Schnee. Was bei euch war es? Minus 11
Grad. Also bei uns war es heute Morgen nur, nur minus 4. Muss man grad mal in mein Home
Assistant gucken. Was haben wir aktuell? Minus 12,8. Was? Da scheint grad die Sonne
drauf, oder? Moment. Okay, da scheint definitiv die Sonne drauf. Da scheint die Sonne drauf.
Das kann ich 12,8 nicht erklären. Und fast 90% Leute, gleich haben wir es. Easy. Capture,
immer noch. Ich sag euch mal was, gestern Abend, ich hab das Handy aufgemacht, YouTube
und jetzt ungelogen. Als erstes, ich hab danach nicht mehr weiter gepostet, als erstes hatte
ich Werbung, Raid Shadow Legends. Das hab ich dann weggemacht, hier, ich hab das Screen
einfach weggemacht und danach hatte ich Werbung für irgend so ein komisches, kennt ihr diese
Werbung, wo man, wie soll ich das beschreiben, wo man so Rätsel, Werbung für Mobile Games,
wo man so Rätsel lösen muss, wo man dann gucken muss, dass die Lava nicht über die
Spielfigur läuft oder dass der nicht ins Wasser fällt und dann muss man irgendwie so komische
Holzblöcke rausziehen und sowas. Kennt ihr diese komischen, ich weiß nicht wie der Kram
heißt, ja? Keine Ahnung, was das für ein Game ist. Hab ich danach gekriegt? So. Und
jetzt kommt, dann hab ich wieder YouTube zugemacht, wieder aufgemacht und wisst ihr was ich dann
gekriegt hab? Ich weiß nicht, ob der Sebaro da ist. Was ich dann, hab ich auf YouTube bisher
erst einmal oder zweimal gesehen. Ich hab danach jetzt ohne Scheiß, ich hab Werbung
für Handtiles gekriegt. Für irgendeine Seite, wo du irgendwelche Handtilesachen lesen kannst.
Das hab ich natürlich nie gesehen. Inklusive Link, wo du irgendwie zwei Probekapitel lesen
konntest und sowas. What the fuck, was ist da los? Hab ich Probekapitel aufgemacht? Ist
ja nicht so, ist ja nicht so, als hätt ich das, hab ich mir gedacht, okay jetzt zeig mal
her was das für eine Werbung. Hab ich Probekapitel aufgemacht und nee, nee, das war kein Film,
du konntest wirklich, das war quasi wie wenn du das als Heft hast, aber halt online. Also
nichts animiertes. Und das war die most generic story aller Zeiten. Irgendwie, Schulkameraden
quartiert sich bei irgendeinem Typ ein, der sonst keine Grills abbekommt und ist übelst
hot und nutzt ihn dann aus und er geht trotzdem voll auf die übliche Story von diesem Scheiß.
Ich weiß gar nicht warum YouTube mir da Werbung von zeigt. Aber ich hab die ersten zwei Kapitel
mal durchgescrollt ja. Und natürlich auch noch zensiert teilweise und so. Wusste ich
gar nicht, dass YouTube dafür, ja genau, der Gottbaba, genau das. Ja, du kennst die Werbung
genau, ich kannte das, TwoMix war das, genau, die Werbung war das, ja, korrekt. Jetzt wo
ich den Namen wieder sehe, jetzt das war es, ja, genau, TwoMix. Gleich Leute, Postchamp,
gleich haben wir es geschafft. Pass auf, jetzt kommt gleich, Daten konnten nicht geschrieben
werden, kaputt. Das ist jetzt G-Bait, oder? Keiner denkt, dass hier was passiert, alle
denken, das ist Teil von der Website. Ich hoffe, dass das Programm jetzt abschließt.
Wie gesagt, ich ragequitte instant, wenn das jetzt nicht funktioniert. Kein Bock, da noch
drei Stunden rumzumachen, dann mach ich das Video in der VM. Jahresabo schon abgeschlossen.
Nee, ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, so doll fand ich das jetzt nicht. Ich fand's mal
ganz interessant, ja, aber ich glaub, das ist kein Service, wo ich ein Jahresabo abschließen
würde. Und mal ganz im Ernst, wenn man sich das angucken will, ich glaube, man muss dazu
gar kein Abo abschließen, das gibt's doch sicherlich auch als Sicherheitskopie irgendwo.
Oh, Leute. Fertig. Close. Alles klar, auf geht's. Wir sind jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, wir entfernen
den USB-Stick jetzt auch sicher. Ich muss nur gucken, dass ich das Richtige entferne,
weil das ist eine externe Platte, die will ich nicht entfernen. Okay, Leute. Wir ejecten
mal den Mass Storage. Klar, nice. Safe to remove. Gut, so. Jetzt gucken wir mal. Zack.
USB-Stick ist auch noch übelst warm. Tastatur umstöpseln. Jetzt gucken wir mal, ob das funktioniert.
F8, F10, F7, ich weiß nicht, ich hemmere mal alles. Okay. Was, was ist jetzt das Richtige
davon? Das ist die, ist das die Onboard? Generic Flashdisk? Das obere ist die Onboard, hm? Okay,
Pause-Cham, Pause-Cham, please, komm, komm, starte, starte, starte, starte das verdammte
Spiel. Ich will nicht, dass es lädt. Hallo? Was jetzt?
Ich hab noch andere USB-Sticks, aber es kann doch nicht sein, dass er nicht geht. Okay,
warte mal, wo hab ich denn einen guten USB-Stick? Irgendwo, warte mal Leute, irgendwo hab ich
den. Ja. Exquisite. Aber ich glaube nicht, dass er am USB-Stick liegt. Ich restarte
noch mal. Nochmal booten, jetzt starte ich das andere. Wir haben, ich bootforce immer
noch den Key, so. Jetzt nehmen wir mal, jetzt nehmen wir mal das obere. Obre ist die Festplatte,
ne? F***, das obere ist die Festplatte, okay. Wir probieren das noch mal aus. Warte mal,
ich hab vielleicht die Festplatte ausgewählt. Ne, hab ich nicht, keck wait. Was hat er denn
für Schmerzen? Windows-Crab, Alter. Okay, ich nehm jetzt einen guten USB-Stick, Leute.
Leg mal enter. Nicht, dass das irgendwas machen würde. Ne, es ist legacy, an und Secureboot
ist aus. Passt. Sonst hätt ich ja gar keinen Mac drauf installieren können. Gut Leute,
also. Jetzt, ich hab jetzt einen guten USB-Stick, einen richtig, richtig zackigen 16G Patriot,
was auch immer. Ist zwar glaub ich auch nur USB 2, aber ein schneller USB 2. Die ISO
ist nicht Corrupted, die ISO an den richtigen Herrschwert. So, Tastatur umstöpseln. In der
Zwischenzeit, ich lass den hier einfach mal weitermachen, vielleicht startet er ja noch.
Neben ISO to USB funzt immer. ISO to USB, gibt's das für Linux? Okay, jetzt muss ich
erstmal Leute, weil ich nicht weiß was auf dem USB-Stick drauf ist hier. Ich hab keine
Ahnung was auf dem USB-Stick drauf ist, deswegen muss ich den erstmal kurz hier connecten.
Mal kurz schauen. Gmask hat 16G. Ist glaub ich gar nichts drauf, großartig. Okay, Linux,
USB, XP, Boot, ISO. Da gibt's doch bestimmt was fertiges. How to make a USB to install
XP from Linux. Aha, Systemer. Was, VirtualBox? Alter, was mit euch los? Alter, was ist das
für eine Anleitung um ein USB-Stick zu erstellen? Nee, das ist für... Okay, nehmen ISO to USB.
Klingt ja äußerst vertrauenserweckend. So, ich mach jetzt erstmal kurz, gpartet auf
und löscht mal den USB-Stick, weil ich weiß nicht genau was da drauf ist, aber ich löscht
es erstmal. Ah, da ist ein Ubuntu Server LTS drauf. Okay, easy, dann kann ich das, da muss
ich das auch nicht löschen, dann ist alles gut. Seht ihr mal wie alt der USB-Stick schon
ist. Okay, da macht nix. Muss ich das jetzt erstmal injecten aus der... Leute, was meint
ihr, legt das an Rufus oder legt das am USB-Stick, dass das nicht funktioniert hat? Ich will
jetzt nur mal kurz gucken, wie schnell das jetzt theoretisch geht. Ich mach's jetzt nicht
nochmal mit Rufus, ich will nur mal kurz gucken, wie schnell es jetzt theoretisch geht. Ob das
jetzt schneller gehen würde. So, Target System, BIOS, MPS, alles gut. Ich will einfach nur
gucken, wie schnell es jetzt geht. Ob das jetzt schneller geht als der alte Crap. Oh,
ein bisschen schneller würde ich sagen, oder? Minimal schneller als der andere. Nur so 300%
schneller. Oder 1000% schneller. Wenn aus XP und UEFI geht, glaube ich nicht gut. Okay,
also, was sollen wir nehmen? USB, nee, ISO to USB. Also nur die Chip. Gibt's das über
USB? Ah, Moment, Search. Sieht schon äußerst vertrauenserweckend aus. Ich weiß nicht, ob
ich das installieren will. Von 2011, exzellent. Nee, gibt's nicht. Windows, XP, USB, Tutable.
200 USB Creator. Das war alles der gleiche Crap, Alter. Ey, wenn der Chat sagt, das funktioniert,
dann nehm ich jetzt das. Ich will das nicht runterladen, was ist das denn? What the fuck?
Da lad ich tatsächlich lieber von Chip runter. Auch wenn Chip übelster Sucker ist. Was schreiben
die Leute in den Bewertungen? Oh nein, nein, nein. Jetzt hab ich's gut bewährt. Ich wollte
noch einfach zu den Bewertungen. AOL Toolbar direkt drauf, ja. Next. Next. Next. Next.
Next. Next. Next. Okay. Drive. Äh, nein, das da, ja. ISO File. Ja, dass ich das im
richtigen rauskomme. Desktop. Es ist doch. Ups. Chip, geh weg. Okay, also. Da wacht doch...
Soll ich FAT32 nehmen? Oder NTFS? Bootable Only Supports Windows, Bootable ESUS, ja.
FAT32. Okay. Burn. Alter, was Crapware wieder. Okay. Ahja. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Ja. Burn. Yes. Ach so, Moment, weil Rufus noch am Start ist. Ah, Moment, das funktioniert
natürlich nett. Beides, beides gleichzeitig, beides gleichzeitig geht natürlich nett.
Warum ist das alles so schwer, Windows? Please. So. War Rufus jetzt eigentlich fertig? Im Hintergrund,
habt ihr gesehen? Okay. ISO. Was, das ist ein Bug? Ich soll den Haken rauslassen? Okay,
perfekte Pogger Software. Das. Burn. Yes. Okay. Mal gucken, ob das jetzt noch langsamer
ist als Rufus. Wenn das noch langsamer ist, dann muss es ja auch noch besser funktionieren,
hab ich gehört. Das ist ja die Logik. Ah Mist, ich hätte FAT32 machen müssen. Was ist
jetzt los? Ah, er macht was, er macht was. Es ist ja wirklich noch langsamer. Nee, das
gäbe ich mit, das gäbe ich mir nicht. Wobei, nee, nee, ich hab nix gesagt, ich hab nix
gesagt. Das ist Windows Progress Balken, da weiß man nicht genau, was Sache ist. Ja,
der Stick ist besser. Ja, ja, das ist sogar ein ganz, ganz guter, der ist zwar alt, aber
ist, okay, der Stick, den ich jetzt hab. Also das andere bootet definitiv nicht, kannst
vergessen. Alter, der ist brutal heiß, der Stick. Übelst, äh. Zieh ich jetzt mal raus,
den anderen Stick. Boomer USB Stick. Ja. Guck mal, wir sind schon zur Hälfte fertig,
Leute. Wir brauchen, wir brauchen, ich glaube, ich sollte das Raspberry Pi Case für den
USB Stick nehmen. Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass wir ne Stunde brauchen oder so, eine
halbe Stunde brauchen, um ein USB Stick zu machen. Ja. Ich weiß schon, warum ich das
letzte Mal in der VM gemacht hab. So, Leute, jetzt überlegte mal. Soll ich es probieren
oder gleich noch mal machen mit FAT32? Ich probier's erst noch mal. Ich probier's erst
noch mal. WinSetupFromUSB, okay, was ist das? Was ist Win? Der Name klingt schon sehr,
sehr vertrauenserweckend. WinSetupFromUSB, nee. CacWade. Was installier ich mir alles
für einen Crap auf dem Rechner, ey? Chip Download, easy. Kann man sich die Bewertung angucken?
Wo sind die Bewertungen? Da ist wenigstens Viren getestet. Chip, der übelste. Die Zeitung
ist auch so richtig... Sack. Ask.com Toolbar hab ich danach drauf. So, auf Stick, geb
alles. Norton Security. Ich hatte früher... Kennt ihr noch? Norton Internet Security Suite
ja. So ein gelbes Logo, ja. Aber das Alte, aber das Alte. So, 2010 rum. Ja, ja, genau,
diesen Crap da. Ja, genau, diesen Crap. Das hatte ich damals am Start, als man noch das
DSL-Modem direkt an Rechner gemacht hat. Okay, alles klar. Gucken wir mal, ob es jetzt funktioniert.
Zack, blubblub, blubblub. Okay, Chat, meint ihr, es funktioniert? Ich schieb ja auf nein.
Oh. Moment, ich hab, ich hab, ich hab nicht richtig, ich hab nicht richtig, äh, Boot,
Button, Boot Forced. What, what the fuck? Alter, ich drück den gleichen Scheiß wie die ganze
Zeit. Da sind wir doch. Patriot, Patriot Memory Map.
Okay. Ob das mit V32 was bringt?
Okay, ich installiere mir das andere, während ich das probiere mit, mit V32.
Das ist ein Act. Aber das ist, das ist die volle Windows XP Experience. Ich hätte nix
anderes erwartet. V32, aus, ISO. Nein. Hat der den USB-Stick jetzt nicht erkannt oder
was? Ah, das ist meine VM, die wieder fragt, ob ich das Nein-Nein-Connect-To-Host. So.
V32. So. Yes. Okay, während er das hier macht, was soll ich noch ausprobieren? Was war das
andere hier? Win Setup from USB. Das klingt auch äußerst vertrauenserweckend, Leute.
Soll ich, soll ich mal sagen. Ventoy. Kann, kann das auch XP? Rufus hat nicht funktioniert.
Ja, Extracted, Downloads. Okay, wir lassen jetzt auch mit V32 spüren.
Was jetzt? Downloads. Hat er jetzt, hat er jetzt irgendwas sinnvolles gemacht? Win Setup
from USB. Ach, da. Okay, wir lassen ihn jetzt noch mal flashen, dann probieren wir es noch
mal. Ich lese jetzt mal ihnen Guide. Windows, XP, USB. Der USB Creator 2.0. Wie viel Scheiße
gibt es dafür eigentlich? Warum kann man nicht einfach, wie jedes x-beliebige Linux-ISO,
die Kram, die Ideen auf den USB stick und es geht einfach. Easy to boot. Power ISO, schlimmer.
Guck, das haben wir alle schon eingestellt. Guck, die machen es auch mit Rufus. Das ist
der Easy USB Creator 2.0. Anfälle. Windows Crap. Ja, guck, Rufus kann das doch angeblich.
Ich habe es mit Rufus probiert, das ging nicht. Okay, wir können es danach noch mal mit Rufus
probieren, wenn das jetzt nicht geht. Windows XP ist 32, doch? Was aber für das Programm,
was es flasht, egal ist. Da steht Rufus ab 2.18 kann das. Ja, weil Linux-ISOs gescheite
sind und nicht so ein Crap wie Windows XP. Okay, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob es jetzt mit
V32 tut. Okay, danach probiere ich es mit Windows Setup vom USB. Wenn wir den Kram jetzt schon
auf dem Computer sehen, ist es schon auf dem USB. Auf, gib alles, ISO to USB. Das ist
ebarr und könnte das echt wissen, dass es so Windows Installierer. Nee, eigentlich keine
Ahnung, ich weiß es nicht. Nee, der Bastel eilt auch viel mit Linux rum. Danach habe ich
auf dem Rechner nach dem ganzen Kack den ich mir hier installiert habe. Gekommnet es am
Start. Okay, also zack. Ich bin gerade am überlegen, soll ich vielleicht mal das an
einen anderen USB-Port stöpseln? Nur mal für den Fall der Fälle, man weiß ja nie.
Okay, erstmal kurz wieder brute force das Boot Setup. Okay. Aha, guck mal, es gibt
zwei Sachen zur Auswahl jetzt. Wir wollen aber nicht den UEFI, wir wollen den normalen
haben. Wir wollen nicht den UEFI, wir wollen den normalen haben, denn Windows XP und UEFI
kommen glaube ich nicht klar miteinander. Alter! Okay. Versuch es jetzt mit UEFI. Was
aber eigentlich funktionieren kann Windows XP? Ha? Postchamp? Postchamp? Nee, jetzt
kommt Mac. Jetzt kommt der Mac Booter. Ja. Okay. Nochmal, zack. B-Stick. Moment, Moment
Leute, ich mache nochmal eine andere Sache. Ich probiere jetzt noch was anderes. Ich mache
die Tastatur vorne dran und den USB-Stick mache ich hinten dran. Das probieren wir jetzt
nochmal aus. Nein, nein, nein, nicht Mac starten. Nein, geht sofort. Leute, was ist jetzt los?
Die Grafik geht? Warum ist die Mac-Grafik jetzt auf einmal in Ordnung? Hä? Fixed?
Okay, das checke ich nicht, aber ich will jetzt keinen Mac. Aus, wieder an. Jetzt booten
wir nochmal, zack. Danke schön für den Zapp. Booter, zwei Monate. Seit wann hast du den?
Ich wusste das selbst nicht, dass ich den habe. Ich habe das wohl irgendwann mal ausprobiert
und habe ganz vergessen, dass ich so ein Ding am Start habe. Ach guck mal, Elgatos wieder
abgeschissen. Unglaublich, mit was für einem Kack man sich hier rumschlagen muss. Also allgemein
gesprochen nicht unbedingt jetzt auf die Elgato-Software nur gemünzt. Wo bin ich denn jetzt gelandet?
Da war ich ja noch nie. Wo bin ich denn jetzt gelandet? Wo kommt denn das jetzt auf einmal
an? What the fuck? Gibt Sachen, die muss man nicht verstehen. Okay, ich habe nicht genug.
Ich muss jetzt echt ausprobieren. Ich probiere jetzt mal die Tasten durch, was es ist. Ich
habe nämlich keinen Bock langsam, die ganzen Kram immer wieder neu zu drücken. Okay, F7
ist es nicht. Probieren wir mal F8. F8, okay. Okay, daran lag es nicht. Am USB-Port liegt
es also nicht. Okay. Hier rein. Es war keine so gute Idee, den Kram auf Hardware installieren
zu wollen. Hätte ich gewusst, was für ein Akt ist. Also wie hieß dieses Ding, was wir
jetzt ausprobieren wollten? WinSetupFromUSB. Okay. China Geheimdienst ist raus. Der Tastatur
geht nicht. Das geht schon gut los. Ah, Moment. Ich habe die Maus eingesteckt, nicht die Tastatur.
Lull. Kein Wunder, dass das nicht funktioniert. So. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6. Exzellent Passwort, ja.
Benutze ich eben die 64-Bit-Version. Auch okay. So. Richtiger USB-Stick. Was muss man da jetzt
machen? Windows XP. Setup. Jawoll. Desktop. Warum findet er nicht mal mein ISO jetzt?
Du musst die ISO mounten. Alter. Was ist das für ein Kack, man? Okay. Okay, ich muss
die ISO mounten, sagt er. Okay, mache ich. Ich mounte die ISO. Mount. Ha. Alles klar.
Ha. Das Ha-Laufwerk. Wo ist das Ha-Laufwerk? Ha. Okay. Select. Keep in mind. Use NTFS.
Okay, wir machen NTFS. Kein Problem. Ja, ja. Ich accepte. Alles gut. Okay. Oder muss
ich das vorher erst NTFS kopieren? Ich muss das bestimmt vorher erst selbst NTFS formatieren,
oder? Okay. Autoformat. Ah. NTFS exquisite. Okay. Go. Ja. Was? Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
Was? What the hell? Ja, mach. Und jetzt? Jetzt erstmal Rechner formatiert. Boah, jetzt
flutscht's. Ach nee. Ha. Jeep baited. Jeep baited. Ich dachte, das ist jetzt auf einmal
alles fertig. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. So einfach ist es nicht. Okay, das geht, aber
das ist, das ist, das, mit der Geschwindigkeit kann ich halbwegs leben. Es wird genau beobachtet,
Chat. Donation drücken. Donate. Oh mein Gott, wir können ihm donaten. Jawoll. Gib her.
Geht nicht. Gib sie mir. Wird nicht mehr donated. Benutzst du irgendwo eigentlich WireGuard?
Nee, nachdem ich mich nicht von außen connecte zu meinem Automatisierungszeug, habe ich da
gerade keinen Anwendungszweck für. Aber wenn ich es machen würde, dann, dann würde ich
WireGuard verwenden mittlerweile. Warum wolltest du jetzt nochmal XP richtig installieren? Weil
ich es cooler finde für das Video, wenn es auf echter Hardware läuft. Dachte ich mir
zumindest. Hätte ich gewusst, dass es so ein Akt ist, hätte ich es wahrscheinlich sein
gelassen.
In welcher Berufsschule warst du eigentlich früher? Werner von Siemens Schule in Frankfurt.
Die Knast Schule. Die Aussicht wie ein Gefängnis. Wie hast du dann das Windows 95 gebootet?
Also erstens war es Windows 98 und zweitens habe ich das nie auf echter Hardware gebootet.
Ja, während das flasht, weil wir es gerade vor dem Thema Berufsschule hatten. Ich war
in dieser Berufsschule. Frankfurt. Die auch sehr gute Bewertung hat, wie man sieht mit
2,1. Leider gibt es da keine, keine Bilder von innen, weil die Schule sieht von innen
wirklich absolut. Ah doch, hier guck mal. Aber da sieht man, da sieht man auch gar nicht
so richtig, richtig viel davon. Sieht aus wie im, wie im Knast in der Schule. Man muss
mal die Gänge sich angucken. Innen. Ja. Freundliches. Ich glaube das letzte, wirklich das allerletzte
was diese Berufsschule hat ist freundliches Ambiente. Das sieht nur wegen dem Licht freundlich
aus. Das sieht wirklich, das sieht ohne Scheiß, das sieht aus wie im Knast da innen drinne.
Was ist die Schule? Nein. Weil die Wände sehen viel zu normal aus dafür. Ne, das ist
was anderes. Guck dir mal die Rezession an, das haben wir schon mal gemacht. Toilet 6,
Building 6, Teaching 6. Ach ne, das ist keine, das sind keine Noten, das ist ähm. Local
Guide. Mario Kuritsch. Ein Stern, ok. Das ist halber Roman, ey. Ein Katastrophengebiet,
erstmal das Gebäude. Die Schule wird eigentlich gar nicht mehr, ja gut, das wurde die damals
schon nicht. Moos vor dem Eingang, drückt die Fliesen aus dem Boden. Ja, das war damals
auch schon so. Das Gebäude ist grau, wie der Star meiner Oma. Ah, Pains Champions. Äh,
so wie innen als außen. Ja, so sieht das von innen ungefähr aus. Das trifft eigentlich
ganz gut, das Sache sieht auch ein bisschen aus wie im Knast. Ja, genau so sah das damals
schon aus. Da hat einer seine Klasse aufgenommen, was man gar nicht darf. Wir haben leider keine.
Alter, guckt euch. Frankfurter Ghetto, alter. Guckt euch die Schule an, ey. Guckt euch
die Schule. Das ist, by the way, gar nicht der Eingang. Das ist, das ist nicht der Eingang,
oder? Der Eingang sah doch anders aus. Das ist, ähm, hinten Richtung Bushaltestelle.
Das ist nicht der Eingang. Ach, das ist beim Parkhaus. Das ist so schlecht, diese Schule.
Aber so siehts da innen drin ungefähr aus. Richtig mies. Okay, Job done, Leute. Auf geht's.
Wir können's noch mal probieren. Soll man das jetzt nicht geht, Rage quitte ich. Mit,
mit Ansage. Okay. Zack. Eject. Alles klar. Zack. USB Stick. USB Stick. Flop. Tastatur.
Was war's? F8, ne? F8 war's. F8. Monkeys! Was ist das?
Was, das ist nicht das Windows Setup, was ist das? Was? Crap for DOS? Die haben, die
haben ne, ne Crap davor gebaut, okay. Vielleicht, vielleicht muss, muss man das machen, weil
das sonst zu verbackt ist bei aktuellen Sachen. Oh, Leute, es ist ein Windows Setup. Poggers,
ein echtes Original Windows Setup. Sachen gibts. Ich fass es net, ich fass es net. Ein
Windows Setup. Real Windows Setup. Na, das war alles, geschafft ist das noch lange net.
Guck mal, der erkennt nämlich meine Festplatte jetzt nicht. Alles umsonst, der erkennt meine
Festplatte nicht. Okay, ich wusste wahrscheinlich noch Festplattentreiber und das war der eine.
Du musst die HDD auf BIOS umstellen. Oh, das kann tatsächlich sein, weil, weil das Data
gedürft vielleicht, na, wobei. Was, was kann man jetzt hier machen? Specify additional device?
Press Enter. Nein, das ist mein USB Stick. Moment, Moment, Moment. Ich kann, ich kann
vom USB Stick auf den USB, ne, das kann eigentlich nicht sein, das ergibt keinen Sinn. Okay,
ich reboote mal. Ich, ich probier vorher noch mal was anderes bevor wir rebooten, äh, beziehungsweise
bevor wir das in BIOS umstellen. Und zwar, jaja, reboote mal. Und zwar mach ich im Crap
die ersten zwei Setups noch mal, die ersten zwei Steps. Was kann man da eigentlich noch
alles auswählen? Autodetect, das war mal jetzt Autodetect and use, genau. Und jetzt hat es
jetzt was gebracht, oder? Mokung, Mokung. Ja, ja. Setup is starting Windows, ja. Force
Camp. Jetzt die Frage, gehts oder gehts nicht? Bam, da ist die Festplatte, da ist die Moab,
da ist die Moab. Chat, erzählt mir nix. Der Chat immer wieder, ne. Da musst du Treiber
runterladen, da musst du BIOS umstellen, ne. Einfach, einfach mal auf die krassen Fachinformatiker
Systemintegration Skills hören, da geht das. So, äh, Free, C, jawoll. C muss ich drücken,
C. Delete, D. Press L. Mein Güde, äh. Yes. Quick. Ich habs geschafft. L für Delete,
erlöschen, was denn sonst? Ja, Windows Logik hat sich in einem nie großartig erschlossen,
was das angeht. Warum muss der da aber eigentlich irgendeinen komischen Craptor vorbauen? Warum
kann man nicht einfach Windows, vielleicht geht Windows XP von USB gar nicht. Vielleicht,
vielleicht täuscht er dem irgendein CD-Laufwerk vor oder sowas. Nach dem Neustart musst du
dann auch Punkt 4 wählen. Ah, ok. Mal gucken, was er macht nach dem Neustart. Ich muss
auf jeden Fall erstmal F8 hemmern, weil sonst versucht er von der Platte zu booten, das
wird nicht funktionieren. Windows XP hat im Setup noch keinen USB-Treiber geladen. Ah,
ja, das wird es wahrscheinlich sein. Wir hätten es, Leute, wir hätten es ohne Scheiß, wir
hätten es auf CD brennen sollen. Einfach auf CD brennen und es hätte sofort funktioniert.
2SDVD. Man sieht schon, es geht jetzt nicht mehr so schnell wie in der VM, aber es funktioniert
fast halbwegs, halbwegs geschwind. Am besten auf Floppy. Ja, Floppy ist zu klein. Übrigens,
schön, wie wir 350 Leute zustauen, 2,5 Stunden USB-Stick zu erstellen für Windows XP. Exzellent,
Leute, exzellent. Aber insgesamt, wenn man weiß, wie es geht, muss man sagen, ist das
Ganze... Übrigens, dass es jetzt so lahm kopiert, liegt bestimmt an der internen Festplatte
und nicht... und an der kacken CPU-Fahrt. Oh, ist das Ding heiß. Alter, das Ding glüht.
Der Rechner, nicht der USB-Stick. Das ist keine Ahnung. 90 Grad, ey. Ja, nee, ich kann
die Hand noch... Also, es ist recht richtig warm. Wir machen danach... Was gibt es denn
für Windows XP zum Hardware-Zeugs auslesen? Früher hat man da... Wie ist das? AIDA64
und Syssoft-Dingsgedöns verwendet. Ja, was gibt es denn für ein schönes Windows XP zum
Hardware-Auslesen? Ah, top. CACW, genau. Ah, top. CPU-Z. Ja, ich will ja auch onboard
Sensor auslesen, sofalls es einen gibt. Genau für sowas wurde Twitch erfunden, so sieht
es aus. HW-Monitor, genau, den verwenden wir dann. Findest du noch die alten XP-kompatible
Version? Klar. Easy. Wisst ihr, was jetzt auch gleich mal schmierig wird? Wir müssen
uns den Firefox 52 runterladen über IE6. Oder ich schiebe den Firefox auf einen USB-Stick
und dann mache ich es über einen USB-Stick rüber. Schon Battlefield-Server? Nee, ich
habe das worden und auch keine Zeit gehabt, mir das anzugucken. Ich weiß, ich habe gesagt,
ich guck's mir diese... Ich hab's mir noch nicht angeguckt. Aber es gibt mittlerweile
auch ein paar ganz gute Rush-Server. Was heißt kein Internet-Explorer? Es gibt nichts anderes.
Okay, jetzt muss ich aufpassen, Chat, jetzt muss ich aufpassen. Muss ich weiter F8 hemmern
und dann Schritt 2 auswählen vom USB-Stick. Ja, 48 Spieler finde ich für manche Rush-Maps
auch ein bisschen viel, aber kannst nix machen. Das ist der 2nd Part. Leute! Ah, yes! Es startet
Windows. Okay, jetzt ist es sich noch nicht so ganz sicher, was es macht. Macht es noch
was? Oh, hat er das Reboot und muss ich jetzt noch mal F8 hemmern? Ich mach noch mal ein
Mal. Was restartet? Ah, ich hätte, glaube ich, gar nichts machen müssen. Er hätte jetzt
von der Platte schon gebootet. Da ist es! Da ist es, Leute! 98 hatten wir schon in der
Platte. Was ist das beste Office Raum? Excellent! Boah, das ist schlecht gewesen. Das mit 35
Minuten stimmt doch eh nicht. Wir kommen uns einfach den Installations-Progress nicht
an. Da merken wir nicht, wie lahm das ist. Oh Mist! Wir brauchen Netzwerk-Treiber! Da
hab ich ja gar nicht dran gedacht. Fuck! Netzwerk-Treiber! Oh, das wird schwierig. Die muss ich dann
auf den USB-Stick machen. Driver-Spy, so einen Crap hab ich noch nie verwendet. So,
okay, also. Oh, ich muss meine Maus anschließen wieder. Zack! Ich bin gerade bei den ganzen
Kabel nicht mehr so richtig durch. Hier, die Maus. Zack! Hallo? Hallo? Maus? Ah, okay,
die Maus hat ein bisschen gebraucht, bis es gecheckt hat. Windows XP hat sicherlich Standard-Treiber
dabei, aber nicht für meine Maus. Also, Customize. Oh Shit, ich brauche noch ein CD-Key, MonkaS.
Okay, German. Location ist EU. Ja, es laggt ein bisschen bei mir hier in der Display-Ausgabe
wegen der Capture-Card, also. So, German. Oh, wo ist es? Hallo? Maus, nicht in die andere
Richtung scrollen. Alter, was ist mit meiner Maus los? Oh, das ist ja Paint-Champ. Scroll-Champ,
ja. Okay, mit der Tastatur bedienen kann man das nicht. Das muss man. Windows möchte,
dass man scrollt. So, Germany. Germany, da ist es, da ist es. Stopp! Ja, die Maus ist
mit Legender-Maus, das ist ein bisschen doof. Exquisite. Okay, US-Keyboard. Oh Gott, das
muss ich jetzt den Scheiß auch noch auswählen. Details. Ach, guck mal, das German-Keyboard
hat er schon drin. Es ist wirklich, das würde ich zum ersten Mal eine Maus bedienen, weil
es da laggt, as fuck. Guckt's euch an. Aber das liegt da in der Capture-Card. Ja, ja, Windows
ist gut. Mach weg. Next, next, next. Ja, gut. Ich mach die Maus mal kurz wieder ab. Ich
dachte, dass das so ein Act ist hier. Okay, also, Tute-Chat heißt das Ding jetzt. Organization,
zack. Oh, nee, Leute, das darf ich euch bestimmt nicht zeigen, den CD-Key. Ich finde es zwar
hängen geblieben, aber wer weiß, bevor ich hier noch Monkart-Tost werde. Okay, Windows-XP.
Oh, ist das lahm. Windows-Serial-Keys eingeben. Ich hab's ja echt vermisst. Hab ich euch
schon erzählt, dass ich mein Serial-Key damals auswendig konnte, weil ich das so oft gemacht
hab. Okay, it's not valid. Na, super. Das stimmt ja mein CD-Key nicht, den ich hier
habe.
Ha, wir haben's. Wir haben's geschafft. Leute, ich mach euch wieder an. Da sind wir
wieder. Excellent. Computer-Name. Cute-XP. Passwort. 123456. 123456. Jawoll, so muss
das sein. Nein, nein, nein, keine Keys posten hier. So geht das. Können wir nicht machen.
Man weiß nämlich nie, ob da irgend einer was dageht, Schade. Auch wenn der ganze Kram
schon irgendwie 85.000 Jahre alt ist. Timezone. Können wir erstmal so lassen, ist mir egal.
Installing-Network. Oh, ich muss ein Netzwerkkabel dran machen, Leute. So. Der hat kein Netzwerk
erkannt. Hätte der Netzwerk erkannt, hätte er mich jetzt gefragt, was er machen soll.
Completing the Installation. Ich hab mich damals immer gefragt, warum sagt er Completing
Installation, und da hat er noch 24 Minuten left. Und das ist definitiv fake. Installing
Startmenu-Items. Als braucht er um 20 Links anzulegen so lang. 20 Links anlegen dauert
200 Nanosekunden. Ist einfach, einfach. Your computer will be faster and more reliable.
Alles klar. Wusst schon immer. Aber schon immer klar. Mit Willows XP wird alles besser.
Jetzt wird's schwierig. Wie kriegen wir Netzwerktreiber für das Ding? Wie kriegen wir Netzwerktreiber?
Jetzt, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt. Vielleicht hat er das Netzwerk doch erkannt. Echte Hardware
mit richtiger Festplatte. Ja, richtig echte Hardware. Deswegen dauert der Kram ja auch
so lang. Welches Modell ist die Sorte ID42? Guck mal hier, jetzt gibt er Gas. Jetzt gibt
er Gas. Jetzt gibt er alles. Muss mal kurz meine LED-Beleuchtung hier einschalten. Ah,
yes. Vielleicht viel besser. Ja, ich hab paar RGBs angemacht, dass das jetzt ordentlich
flutscht hier. Wo so die letzten Prozentpunkte aus der Performance hier rausgeholt wird.
Ich hab meine Fensterbeleuchtung gerade angemacht. Ist ja schon wieder langsam dunkel. Ja, da
muss ich dann wahrscheinlich gleich hin auf diesen Link, ja. Als erstes muss ich jetzt
aber mal gucken, ob er nicht vielleicht doch den Netzwerk hat, der erkannt hat. Surfing
Internet. Safe, fast and flexible. Ah ja. Gut, man kann ihn ja nicht vorwerfen. Man kann
ihn ja nicht vorwerfen, dass die 2000, wann kam das raus? 2003 oder so. Zwei nicht, da
wussten was 2020 ist. Da kann man ihn ja nicht vorhalten. So, Bootchamp, Bootchamp. So,
ich mach jetzt nichts mit dem USB-Stick, der soll jetzt gefälligst von der Platte booten.
Bootchamp, auf. Da ist es. Da ist es, Enter. Bringt nichts. Man muss alt abdrücken, sonst
darf man mit der Tastatur nicht Enter drücken. Geiles Zeug. Yes, perfekte Auflösung. Kann
man da rüber auf OK. Welcome. Next, ich hab die Maus grad nicht dran, deswegen. Jaja,
mach Automatik-Updates, alles gut, mach. Next. Borders. Hallo? Muss ich jetzt ernsthaft
hier durchtappen, um auf Next zu kommen? Usability pur. Welcome. Ok, jetzt muss ich die Maus umstöpseln.
Also, die Maus, die ich hier grad am Vorschaurechner hab, auf den. Also, der Link von der Netzwerk-Port,
der Link ist ab. Und. Computer might be at risk. Leute, ich hab vergessen, wie macht
man Netzwerk-Config? Control Panel. Control Panel Netzwerk oder so? Network Internet Connection.
Kannst du den Chat nach oben schieben, ja? Nee, kann ich nicht. Erkennt man da oben nix.
Nein, Network Place. Wo sind die Netzwerk-Adapter-Settings gewesen? Die Maus lag so krass. Nein, Windows
Tour gehen wir nicht auf den Sack. Weck. Aha, die Maus. Ach, jetzt kann ich. Ok, sobald
ich den Display-Treiber hab, kann ich checken, ob's im Cam Link besser funktioniert, lag-freier
funktioniert. Ja, das hab. Ok, er hat keine Netzwerk-Dinger erkannt. Ok, äh. Tja, dann
muss man den USB-Stick. Dann muss der USB-Champ jetzt ran. Alles klar. USB-Testatur umstöpseln.
Äh, langsam könntest du echt einen KVM-Switch kaufen, das wird schon lohnen. So, USB. Und
jetzt nimm ich mal den Link, den die Leute in den Chat gepostet haben. Ok, also. Jetzt
probieren wir erstmal aus, ob der, ob der Cam Link funktioniert. Weil, der sollte lag-freier
sein. Der Cam Link, der Cam Link leuchtet, das ist doch schon mal gut. Geht das mit der
gleichen Software? Was? Hat er den Cam Link nicht gefunden? Äh. Weiß er doch, ha! Oh,
Leute, es ist so lag-frei. Es ist so lag-frei. Ich kann die Maus einfach bedienen, ohne dass
es laggt. Es funktioniert einfach. Nice. Guck mal. Was er... Guck mal, hier. Der erkennt
ja schon die richtige Auflösung. Der Cam Link direkt in OBS hat rumgespackt, das letzte.
Ist das das, was der Chat meinte, warum der Cam Link zackt? What? Ha. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
What? Ich hätte nichts machen sollen, Leute. Ich hätte nichts machen sollen. Ich hätte
einfach die Finger verlassen sollen. What? Alter. Ok, dann mach ich halt die Capture
kann, bis ich die Auflösung umstellen kann. Leute, ich blick bei den Kabeln grad nicht
mehr durch. Das ist zu viel, äh, zu viel Kabel. Input. Hier ist das USB-Kabel. Wo ist
das USB-Kabel? Andere Ende noch finden. Aber jetzt laden wir erst mal den Netzwerktreiber
runter. Off. Camp-Camp. Initialisier den mal ein. Ja? Come on, bro. Mach. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Es ist gar kein großer Unterschied zwischen Cam Link und Capture Card. Bei mir ist der
Unterschied, dass meine Capture Card alt ist und leckt. Sag mal, will der mich verarschen?
Das ging doch eben auch noch. Jebaiten. You got jebaited. Ich starte gleich einfach neu.
Ich hol mir jetzt erst mal den Netzwerktreiber für das Ding. Ne, ne, das mit dem Profil
macht keinen Unterschied. Das ist, das hatte ich schon ein paar Mal. So, also. Iiih, was
ist das für ne Webseite? What the hell? Phone Loads. Fuck. Software Treiber. Network. Wie
aus dem eins und eins. Baukasten. Ja, aber echt. Network. Network. Ethernet. Tja. Was
können wir da für nen Treiber nehmen? Hat irgendjemand noch was gepostet? Ah, guck
mal hier. Hier gibts gleich mit Download Link. Hat einer in den Chat gepostet. Realtek LAN.
Realtek klingt schon mal gut. Cancell. Realtek LAN für 32 Windows 7. Ok, probieren wir das
mal aus. Probieren wir das mal aus. Dann auf den USB Stick und dann starte ich die Box
neu, dass die Capture Card wieder funktioniert. Realtek LAN, Alter. Mach Auge. Ah, hier auf
Setup drauf ist ok. Normalerweise bin ich nicht so pipslicher wie der Palms hier mit
dem Entfernen, aber ich traue dem Scheiß grad nicht. Ok, wunderbar. Jetzt haben wir
Netzwerk. Ich schalte das Ding jetzt noch mal aus. Ich schalte das ganze Ding jetzt
noch mal aus. Und ähm. Und wieder an. In der Hoffnung, dass das jetzt sich fixt mit
dem Output. Ah, siehst du. Easy. Funktioniert. Da sind wir. So und jetzt stelle ich es nochmal
um auf 1080p und dann probiere ich es mit dem Cam Link. Settings, Settings. Jawoll, Settings.
Come on. Ah. Ok. Apply. Ah. Yes. Sehr gut. Alles klar. So und jetzt machen wir das zu.
Und du machst den Cam Link wieder dran. Und mit dem Cam Link geht es dann auch lagfrei.
Hoffentlich. Ok, Cam Link ist dran. Cam Link macht auch komische, komische, Plinkt auch
komisch vor sich hin. Ach so, im Moment hier Elgato, Elgato. Easy Workflow, ja. Easy ist.
Fuck. Hallo? Braucht das, muss man das erst doppelt starten? Das ist, weißt du was? Ja.
Ah. Da ist es. Poggers. Äh, hallo? Ok, es. Da sind wir. Ohne lag, Leute. Ohne lag, wir
haben es geschafft. Die krasseste Mausbeschleunigung aller Zeiten, ey. What the fuck? Leute, ich
bewege die Maus einen Zentimeter. Nice, nice, nice. So, USB Stick. Oder wie die coolen
Leute sagen würden, USB. Ja, Pictures. Natürlich, Windows Setup ist Pictures. Was denn sonst?
Kann man das nicht irgendwie Fullscreen einstellen noch? Das muss doch irgendwie auch ohne diesen
komischen Rand gehen. PC 1080p. Irgendeiner hat eine Idee? Aber wie kann man denn nichts
einstellen, ne? Das geht erst, wenn die Grafiktreiber richtig installiert sind. Vorstellen. 1080p
ist doch 1080p, das ist auf dem Grafikkarten Treiber egal. Die Auflösung haben wir schon
geändert. Ok, Realtag-Lan. Äh. Boah, das ist aber mit die Maus lag zwar immer noch,
allerdings ist es deutlich besser zu bedienen als vorher. Das geht aber schnell. What is
happening? Warum nervt der jetzt rum, wenn ich noch mal auf Next drücke? Warum braucht
der so lang zum extrahieren? Ich meine, die Festplatte ist langsam, aber doch nicht so
langsam. 5 MB ZIP Archiv. Ah gut. Setup. An. Nein! Das geht. Wir installieren das direkt
über den Geräte-Manager. Wir machen das direkt über den Geräte-Manager. Das geht
bestimmt, das geht. Äh. Moment. Wo war der Geräte-Manager noch mal? Hier, ne? Ok. Wir
haben Network-Controller, Ethernet-Controller, Network-Controller. Ja, was davon ist jetzt
das Richtige? Leute, ich hab keinen Plan, ob das Sinn ergibt, was ich hier mache. Ah!
Ja. Äh, ok, das hat schon mal nicht funktioniert. Oh. Ups. Es. Wollt ihr den PC-Speaker im
Hintergrund? Ja, Windows nervt nicht rum. Reboot jetzt und dann geht's. Ah! Das, ok,
das ist WLAN und das sind die zwei Onboard-Controller. Die rebooten jetzt und dann geht's, Leute,
ich sag's euch. Und ansonsten müssen wir jetzt noch mal den Treiber suchen. Oh ne, es wird
Pains-Champ ich hoch drei. Eno-Signal. Sag mal, kann es sein, dass der Cam Link irgendwie
Probleme hat mit, mit, mit, mit changenden Auflösungen? So ein bisschen. Ihr könnt auch
gleich den Start-Sound hören, wenn's denn funktioniert. Ich mach mal den Cam Link kurz
rein und wieder raus. Ich glaub, der Cam Link hat echt Probleme mit, mit changenden Auflösungen,
was, was aber Massive-Massive-Suck ist. Vielleicht muss ich doch wieder die Capture-Card verwenden.
Cannot connect to your Capture-Device. Das wird nicht erkannt, ok. Ist gut. Was? Eno-Capture-Device-Found,
das ist doch dran. Boah, ey, manchmal. Eno-Signal, warum? Eno-Signal-Cac-Wait. Warum ist denn das
jetzt? Hm, also gehen tut's. Ok, ich mach, ich mach die Elgato wieder dran, die andere.
Ab der Kram, dann hab ich Lack und mit Lack ist ja noch schlimm. Ich hab jetzt die Auswahl
zwischen Lack as Fuck oder zwischendurch abkacken. Ist natürlich geile, geile Auswahl, ne. Also,
kann sich ja gar nicht entscheiden, was besser ist. So, wo ist das USB? Anschließen, zack.
Ich weiß, dass ich direkt den OPS reinmachen kann, das bringt aber nichts, wenn das abkackt
in der offiziellen Software, kackt das in OBS auch ab. Und das einzige Problem, was wir
dann haben, ist, dass ich OBS komplett neu starten muss, wenn das da den Geist aufgibt.
Hab ich Windows jetzt gecrashed oder was? Hab ich jetzt Blue Screen? Ok, ich schalt
den Rechner nochmal komplett aus. Komplett aus, nochmal neu an. Wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich
hab ich mit dem Treiberinzidenz dafür gesorgt, dass Windows nur noch Blue Screens hat und
es gar nicht mehr bootet oder so. Ok, Game Capture, auf, mach, zeig. Ok, 30 Minuten initialisieren
für die Capture Card, meinetwegen. Weißt, ich weiß nicht, warum man da so lang für
auch, aber ok, soll er machen. Du kannst kein Signal detekten, weil es aus ist. Ok,
jetzt mach ich den Rechner an, jetzt sollte eigentlich was erkennen. Postchamp? Aha. Weiß
nicht mehr, wie viel ich in meiner Ausbildung verdient hab. Oh, es laggt. Benutz doch einfach
Linux. Hä? Was soll mir das denn jetzt sagen? Ok, und geht das jetzt? Ok, wir gucken jetzt
mal, ob der das jetzt erkannt hat, aber wahrscheinlich hat er immer noch Treiberprobleme. Das mit
lag ist wirklich, ne, ok, fuck, dann brauchen wir eine Netzwerktreiber. Ich probier das jetzt
ohne Scheiß, ich probier das jetzt mit dem Cam Link, ich kann nix machen, wenn das so,
ich krieg Anfälle, wenn das rumleckt, wie Sau. Ich mach jetzt den Cam Link nochmal dran,
ich geht. Dann nehm ich das Video mit einer VM auf. Ok, der Cam Link meint, es geht.
Mit Linux wär das nicht passiert, das stimmt. Die Jungs könnt ich das Video gleich aufnehmen.
Ja, Elgato, gibs uns, gibs uns, zeigts uns. Aha, nice. Ok, also jetzt können wir es uns
angucken. Wie das rumspackt, guck mal, der heitet das gar nicht. Also, was ist denn da
überhaupt drinne? Realtek, PCI, GBE, also. Ah, du große Kacke. Leute, hier, kann es
leider nicht größer machen. Ich such mir jetzt einen Realtek Treiber. Ich such mir
jetzt da einen passenden Treiber für, Tastaturumstöpseln. Das hätt ich nicht gedacht, so ein Akt ist
der jetzt auch noch den Gramm zum Laufen zu kriegen. Ok, das mach ich unter Linux, da
kann ich ja auch auf komischen Seiten gehen. Realtek, GBE, ne, was war denn da drinne?
Zotek, Zbox, ID 200. Müssen wir erst mal gucken, was da für einen Netzwerkadapter
drin ist. Leicht Shady, warum ist das Shady? Ach ja, Realtekdownload.com. Ja, das klingt,
ich such mal selbst grad, ob ich es so finde. So, IO-Ports, LAN, ja, super. LAN, Leute,
ist dabei. Brauche ich, brauche ich Manual. Manual. Manual. Realtek, was ist denn da für
einen Chipsatz drinne? ME, ME 521? Das ME, das ist doch dieser Realtek, alles in einem
Treiber, oder? Manual. Da. Realtek. Realtek. Warum machst du nichts mal mit dem Friseur,
weil der Friseur grad nichts macht? Ah ne, das war was anderes. Das muss man auch irgendwie
rauskriegen, was da für einen, für einen... Zbox, ID, Realtek. Was ist denn da drinne?
LAN. Audio-Codex. Chat, please. She baitet mich nicht. Download dir das Tool unter HW-Info.
Gibt viele Möglichkeiten, was man machen kann, ich muss aber erst mal, aha, okay. Also, es
gibt doch bestimmt noch ein Realtek-GBE-Windows-XP. Halt mal her, was ist das da? Realtek-Download.
Das klingt irgendwie... Ob ich schon mal das installieren will? Auf der anderen Seite,
ohne Netzwerktreiber kann ja nichts passieren. Also, man muss doch irgendwie rauskriegen,
was da für eine Hardware drin ist. Realtek. Haben wir das hier nicht gesehen? Geht man das
hier nicht raus? 8, 1, 6, 1. Anhand was kriegt man von diesen ID-Cells raus, was es ist? Ja,
okay. Jetzt wird es natürlich ein bisschen komplizierter. Es muss doch irgendwo stehen,
was da für eine Netzwerk-Karte drin ist. Realtek. RTL, deswegen heißt es immer irgendwas mit RTL.
RTL 8. Fuck, was haben wir denn da jetzt?
Okay, also, gucken wir mal. Download-Drivers, Windows XP. XP, oh nee, XP. Ja, LAN-Drivers,
XP, excellent. Gucken wir mal rein. Okay, das können wir tatsächlich schon mal... So,
und was HW-Info? Das können wir wirklich auf den USB-Stick machen, da sagt uns, was drin ist.
Eigentlich keine schlechte Idee. Hat das schon mal jemand verwendet? Ich bin mir jetzt gar
nicht sicher, ob ich das irgendwann schon mal ausprobiert habe. Portable, freedowner. Aber
das läuft bestimmt nicht unter XP, oder? Das läuft doch gar nicht mehr unter XP. Portable
von DOS. Okay, Leute, ich mach da einfach beides auf den USB-Stick jetzt drauf. Freedownload,
local, ja. Zack. Freedownload, zack. Portable. Ist das 32? Ah, gut.
Naja, den Realtek-Driver haben wir schon, aber der geht nicht. Okay, zack, dann machen wir
das jetzt auf den USB-Stick drauf. Ach ja, wie sehr hab ich es vermisst, Windows rumzubasteln.
War jetzt eigentlich zum größten Teil G-Bait, aber wenn ich ehrlich bin, so ein bisschen Spaß
macht es trotzdem. Es ist zwar fail ohne Ende, aber cool ist es trotzdem irgendwie. Ich habe
es schon 15 Jahre nicht mehr gemacht. Ziehen wir das mal raus, stöpseln das da wieder rein
und installieren uns den Kram mal. Das da ist es gewesen. HWinfo32, jawoll. Please
G unter Windows XP. Ha, ha, ha. Ho, ho, Postchamp, Postchamp. Ha. Okay. Und wo sehe ich jetzt
was für ein Network? Aha, RTL, da wisst ihr was es ist. Also, es ist ein RTL 8168 und da
brauchen wir jetzt einen für Windows XP. 8168, okay. RTL 8168 XP. Realtek. Das ist die offizielle
Seite von denen, ne? Bekommen uns. Liats. Das sieht ja richtig gut aus, die Seite. Genau
so stelle ich mir Windows XP Downloads ein vor. Okay, Windows XP 2 von 2009. Perfekt,
das brauchen wir. Genau die. Also, was haben wir hier? So gassigniert. Was willst du denn
besseres haben? Download Driver. Save. Jawoll. Achso, ich muss den USB-Stick dran machen.
Pack. Pack Triple U. Danach kann ich endlich rüber kopieren. Hat er jetzt downloadet? Ja.
Open. Nein. Gehst du weg? Lull. Da wird nichts gescannt. Sobald da irgendwas gescannt wird,
ist RIP. Hallo? Windows. I'm in. Ist vor allem da gerade abgeschissen, oder was? Ich
weiß nicht. What the fuck? Was ist das denn jetzt? Hacker. Der Hacker man hat übernommen.
Ja, das wird es sein. Das sind doch nicht mal unofficial Drivers, das sind official
Drivers. Okay, Task Manager. Vor allem bei Workstation. Bam. Ja, was willst du machen,
wenn es abkackt, ne? Okay, wollen wir es noch mal probieren, zu tracken, droppen? Jetzt
geht es gar nicht mehr. What? Sind die Forever Tools jetzt abgeschissen, oder was? Alter,
Pains, Champ. Okay, dann mount ich das Ding halt unter Linux. Mount Champ. Also, fdisk-sdb
ja, passt auch. This file wasn't safely closed. Exiting. Ja, gut. Ah ne, Fixing, Fixing. Okay,
WP, Home, Max, Downloads, Downloads, XP, ZIP, Sync, zack, Sync, Unmount. Das ist so einfach
wie fertig. So, gehen wir rüber. Und stöpseln den USB-Stick dran und sind jetzt endlich mal
unsere Netzwerktreiber. Air Open. Das war keine gute Idee, das Schieben. Pains, Champ.
Okay, zack. So, also, was heißt, Extract? Naja, Extract immer. Gibs mir, Extract. Okay,
Windows Champs, wie geht denn das jetzt? Muss ich jetzt hier noch mal sagen, was geht jetzt,
immer uninstall? Bäm, jawoll. Wissenschaft von Windows, keine Ahnung. Windows XP, aber
so, von Windows XP. What? CacWaite? CacWaite, warum installierst du das noch mal? I found
your hardware, okay. Location, und jetzt sag ich im Desktop, XP. Und, gehts jetzt? Oh
Mann, warum? Das sind Windows XP-Treiber. Wie kann das sein, dass das Windows XP-Treiber
nicht funktioniert? Ich hab Windows XP-Treiber extra dafür, das muss gehen. Was ist das denn
für ein Cac? Ein Problemakult, hohohoho. Warum nicht? Windows. Äh Leute, der hat den
falschen Treiber installiert. Der hat den falschen Treiber installiert, guckte mal.
Der hat den falschen Treiber installiert, das ist nicht der. Der hat mich debated. Warum
wird nicht einfach Linux verwenden? Ich mach das, um Windows XP zu verwenden. Natürlich
könnte ich Linux verwenden, aber dann kann ich den ganzen Kram auch sein lassen. Update
Treiber. Oh. Weil der Treiber, den ich hier hab, ist angeblich eine fünfer Version,
mit, ähm, von 2009. Okay, don't, I choose the Treiber. I have disk, aber, tja. Natürlich
nicht. Netrille hab ich, netrille. Ah, yes. Okay. Äh, der da war's, ne? 8168 8111. Habt
ihr's euch gemerkt? War das der hier? Oh. Jaja. Windows, mach einfach und nervt mich
nicht. No. Okay, das, das könnte durch den Restart behoben sein. Das könnte, das könnte
tatsächlich durch den Restart behoben sein. Ich inszenier jetzt das andere auch nochmal.
Ich hab hier zwei, ich hab ja zwei, zwei Interfaces. Fdisk, jaja. Was haben die sich
bei Microsoft eigentlich dabei gedacht, Alter? Was ist das für ein Kram? Das ist ja wirklich
absolute Zubutung. Yes. Hoffentlich kann ich Reboot und Cambling kack nicht wieder ab.
Yes. No Signal. Das stimmt doch überhaupt nicht. Cambling. Natürlich ist da ein Signal.
Leute, hört ihr's? ASMR-Lüftersounds. Also, ich muss ja sagen, der Cambling beeindruckt
mich jetzt nicht so wirklich, wenn der dabei immer abkackt, ne? Wisst ihr das? Das, das
ist ziemlicher, ziemlicher Fail-Champ. Kein, kein Cambling-Champ. Jetzt sind Tage Rückgaben
recht. Ja, hast du recht. Ich, ich kauf ihm besser ne Capture-Card. Ne moderne. So, was
passiert, wenn ich den Cambling jetzt raus zieh und wieder rein stecke? Wie geht er denn
dann wieder? Weil, sag mal, so ein Windows sollte mittlerweile gebootet haben. Der Cambling
erkennt ernsthaft, der erkennt nix. Das ist ja witzig. Der erkennt jetzt kein Output.
Ich wette mit euch, wenn ich die Capture-Card anschließe und ausmache, dann geht's wieder.
Aber meinst du, ich soll den Hardware-Rad-Trick machen? Nix, nix in die Rücksendung reinstecken.
Ah ja, exzellent. Gute Idee, gute Idee. No Capture Device Found, was ja auch schwachsinnig
ist, weil ich hab's grad angeschlossen. Ah, da ist es wieder. No Signal. Warum ist das
eigentlich? Hast du viel an deinen USB-Ports ran? Es geht ja, es geht ja, wenn ich danach
umstecke und mit der anderen Capture-Card. Das ist einfach, äh, glaub ich kaputt. Oder
was heißt kaputt? Einfach nicht, nicht gut gemacht. Das hat auf jeden Fall wieder gestartet.
Ne, der erkennt das nicht. Wisst ihr, was ich jetzt mal mach? Ich, Leute, ich schalte
mal aus. Ich schalte aus und wieder ein oder gucken wir mal, ob's der Cam Link dann erkennt.
Okay, da hat er noch nicht mal den Cam Link an sich erkannt. Geh mal in die Einstellung
vom Cam Link, da gibt's ja nichts zum großartig einzustellen. Ich muss erst mal warten, bis
der Cam Link überhaupt wieder auftaucht, bis der sich dazu herabgelassen hat. Was willst
du denn in der Einstellung großartig machen? PC, fertig. Kannste nichts einstellen, großartig.
Xbox. Stell mal das Input Device um. Chat, what? Was für ein Input Device? Da gibt's
überhaupt nichts. Ihr habt die Software doch noch nie verwendet. Da gibt's doch überhaupt
nichts zum Umstellen. Da kann man nichts machen. Das ist ja eigentlich auch der Vorteil an dem
Kram, dass es einfach funktioniert. Wenn es dann funktioniert. Okay, ich mach jetzt noch
mal an und gucke, ob es jetzt funktioniert. Wenn es bootet damit. So, er startet. Nö,
das juckt ihn einfach nicht. Das ist ihm einfach YOLO. Das Cam Link ist ihm egal. Ist ihm wurscht.
Juckt nicht weiter. Ist ihm vollkommen egal. Okay, dann Capture Card dran. Das mach ich
jetzt aber nicht bei jedem Reboot. Ich muss auf 50 Milliarden mal Rebooten, ey. Was passiert
eigentlich, wenn ich Cam Link, wenn ich Cam Link und Dings gleichzeitig dranmache? Implodiert
dann der Rechner. Ah, okay, das ist schon mal gut gemacht. Man kann den Krempel einfach
umschalten. Da muss ich nicht immer abziehen. Das ist schon mal ganz gut. Das ist okay.
One moment, please. Okay, gut. Aber man kann beides machen. Das ist schon mal, das ist
schon mal schick. No Signal. Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil er den nicht gecheckt hat. Jetzt noch
mal ausschalten muss und wieder anschalten muss. Wir sind auf der Game Capture. Oh Leute,
ich hab die Big Brain Idee der Big Brain Ideen. Ich mach HDMI Pass through von der Capture
in den Cam Link. Pass mal auf. It's Big Brain Time.
Der Cam Link hat das wirklich erkannt gerade, ne?
Wo ist das Problem, Elgato? Das müsste aber eigentlich funktionieren. Jetzt mal ernsthaft,
es muss eigentlich funktionieren, der Pass through vom HDMI. Staub im HDMI Port. Also
der Pass through müsste eigentlich gehen. Ich überleg grad, hab ich noch ein anderes
HDMI Kabel mal hier auf die Schnelle. Wartet mal kurz, ich guck mal, welches HDMI Kabel
der Port. Fuck. Ohne Scheiß, Leute, VGA wird einfach funktionieren.
Alter, ich hab, glaub ich, kein anderes HDMI mehr hier. Braucht ja sonst auch so selten
HDMI Kram. Warte mal, hier ist die Kiste an Kabel, da guck ich mal kurz.
Oh, schau mal, hier ist die Kiste an Kabel, da guck ich mal kurz.
Scheiße, ich hab nur eins. Ich hab nur eins gefunden. Ich hab nur eins gefunden, okay.
Das probieren wir jetzt aus. Cam Link. Das ist das fetteste Starstar HDMI Kabel aller
Zeiten, ey. Aber das ist 50 Billionfach vergoldet und abgeschirmt mit Diamanten und Platin und
qualifiziert von Bill Gates persönlich, das geht jetzt.
Es geht ernsthaft. Ach nee, warte mal, das ist jetzt die Game Capture. Wo ist der Cam
Link hin? Sag mal, ist der Cam Link gerade gecrashed oder wie?
Come on, Elgato, please. Warum ist das grün? Okay, ich probier jetzt erst mal, ob der Cam
Link funktioniert. Es liegt auf jeden Fall nicht am HDMI Kabel. Gleich nehm ich, gleich
nehm ich den HDMI Splitter. Ich sag's euch, ein Splitter und mach da, nee, nee, mach
ich nicht. Das dauert mir zu lange. Was wegen HDCP? Moment, warum ist das HDCP?
Keg Weight? HDCP? Ich nehm gleich Skat. Okay, aber nee, mit XP hat das nichts zu tun, weil
direkt geht's ja auch. So Leute, wisst ihr was? Scheiß drauf. Warte mal, können wir?
Cam Link Disable HDCP. Scheiß drauf. Das Problem ist, das hat doch auch kein HDCP.
Wo ist denn da die Logik? Das hat kein HDCP, aber der Cam Link denkt, das Pass-Through-Signal
hat HDCP? What? Da gibt's für mich keinen Sinn. Geht der Netz das Netzwerk? Weil wenn
jetzt das Netzwerk nicht geht, müssen wir gar nicht weitermachen. Sackt halt ein bisschen
mit Maus-Lag, ne? Massive Maus-Lag. So, Hardfair.
Ja, gut, jetzt hab ich keine Ahnung mehr.
Jetzt hab ich keine Ahnung mehr. Wird anscheinend mit Netzwerk nix, ne? Ich glaube, das liegt
daran, weil ich die vierte Schicht des Osimodells nicht wusste. Das wissen die bei Realtek.
Klar hatte das schon WLAN. 8.1, das hab ich ja gemacht. Kann das Ding nach Treibern für
mich suchen oder so? Ich will diese ganzen Scummy-Treiber-Installier-Software nicht verwenden.
Könnte sein, dass du den falschen Treiber ausgewählt hast. Ist schon möglich. 8.1.6.8.8.1.
Zipiel, haben wir schon das Richtige. 8. Eigentlich hab ich da, schau.
Das wird alles.
so chat, was haben wir hier?
für xp? ist da was für xp dabei? ok, nice. das nehmen wir jetzt. das nehmen wir jetzt chat. ist da aber mein? das ist nicht der 8168? der ist da nicht dabei.
ok. ich habe ihn als infall geguckt. excellent. nice. dann machen wir das jetzt.
wo ist der usb stick? jawoll. also was haben wir hier? realtech? ich dachte realtech.cz ist die richtige seite. ja was denn jetzt? anscheinend doch nicht, ja?
unofficial realtech driver site. alles klar, alles klar. es hat 5 schmieren runtergeladen wahrscheinlich. ok. windows xp auto install programm. nein, nein, nein, nicht per mail.
was?
alles klar, alles klar. ok, ok, ok, gut.
das sind zwei komplette rutsche. k, n, 5, s, j, n. ok. s, p, p, z. was ist das? y? umgedrehtes y? e.
das ist ein k. easy, easy, easy, easy as fuck. ok, nice.
ok. jetzt aber, jetzt aber, leute. capture card fällt mir gleich runter. so. ok. open.
gibt. was da? zack. mit lag ist es so toll zu bedienen. ja, ja, ja, ja. alles klar windows. kein problem. ach, yes.
ich komme mir vor, als habe ich erst einmal aus in der hand. so. und, und was? setup. exquisite. oh, diese grafik hier. rtx activated für den installer.
darüber müssen wir mal battlefield spielen jetzt.
ob der jetzt funktioniert? leute. der wizard ist ab, der wizard ist abgeschlossen. meine maus ist weg. ah ne, meine maus ist wieder da.
ob das jetzt geht?
wirklich funktioniert, oder? hat, hat der überhaupt irgendwas gemacht? eboot. genau so gut wie der, wie der cz3 war, ja.
ok, es ist, er sagt zumindest, es ist installiert. yes, ich will abbrechen. ok, vielleicht muss ich jetzt noch, ok, ich reboote mal, leute. ich, ich reboote mal, ich reboote mal, man weiß ja nie.
restart. zack. ja. ja, wie wäre es mit restarten? war er kein bock gehabt, hatte ich gedacht, nein, mach ich nicht.
ah, jetzt, ok. so, leute, meint ihr, netzwerk geht jetzt?
50, 50, ja oder nein? würde sagen, es ist nicht mal 50, 50.
leute, es geht, es geht, es geht, es geht. komm, wir haben netzwerk.
connected. nice. excellent, excellent. das heißt, hier der grafikkartentreiber.
ok, das ist eine gute idee. leute, wir installieren jetzt den grafikkartentreiber und hoffen, dass der cam linkt, das dann checkt, verzögerungsfrei, lagfrei.
so, ich mache auf den usb stick den grafikkartentreiber drauf. copy. ja, schau, komm an. war null umständlich, aber so war das unter, ohne mist, so war das oft unter windows xp.
so, übelst random, du wusstest, du wusstest ja aus übelst welchen scam seiten die sachen runterladen und sowas.
wofür machst du das alles? weil ich ein video mache über windows xp.
so, jetzt wird der grafikkartentreiber installed.
da unten ist der mauszeiger, off. mauszeiger lag.
da, nvidia, gibs, gibs mir.
also leute, ich hab das doppelt angeklickt, das tut sich aber grad nix.
äh, hallo?
also, das liegt jetzt nicht an der maus, das usb 2 port, ja.
also, mich würd sich wundern, wenn das ein usb 0.9 port oder irgendwie sowas ist.
was ist denn jetzt, warum geht denn das nicht?
der usb stick ist abgekackt, seh ich das richtig?
ah ja, excellent, sehr gut, sehr gut.
wenn ich den usb stick rausziehe, passiert doch einfach gar nix.
leute, leute, leute, wir habens, wir habens, wir habens ge-, oh.
darf ich das neu öffnen?
ah ja, sehr nett, sehr nett.
sehr nett.
ich, ich ziehs mal auf die festplatte rüber.
ach, jetzt, jetzt darf ichs runnen, oder was?
ich hoffe, das funktioniert mit dem camlink danach.
massiv and zippos?
der winnosexplorer war ja noch nie die große errungenschaft von microsoft, ja.
mit snapshot will das nix.
ich würd sofort nen snapshot machen, wenns geht, das glaubt ihr aber.
ok, jetzt musste man, der hat ja gar nicht installiert, der hat jetzt ja erst entpackt.
das war ja so richtig, ne, doch.
ok.
die gute alte geforce experience, bevor sie geforce experience hieß.
eh, force champ?
was checkt der da?
30 stunden? ah ok.
der hat gewartet, bis ich den mauszeiger bewege, um dann zu sagen, ja jetzt bin ich fertig, jetzt musss wieder runtergehen.
express, express vpn.
der checkt nix, ich glaube auch nicht, dass der was checkt, ich glaube ehrlich gesagt,
dass der im hintergrund entpackt und es nicht sagen will.
pcilookup.com
also solange ich da ohne lag drauf zugreifen kann, ist schon mal gut.
warum downloadet das so 30 kilobits pro sekunde?
das ist ein dual core zeleron mit ner ollen grafikkarte 500 gigabyte festplatte.
das kommt mit windows xp klar, das ist fast sogar schon ein ticken zu neu.
meint ihr der downloadet wirklich oder der tut nur so?
jetzt mehr ernsthaft, vielleicht kann der nicht downloaden und die handeln den fehler gar nicht, dass der download nicht geht.
task manager hatte damals noch kein netzwerk oder?
aber die, aber die, man konnte sich glaube ich übertragungsgeschichten oder?
ne, der downloadet nix.
das wäre ja auch definitiv zu einfach, wenn das funktionieren würde.
vor allem, welches.net framework?
da könnte ichs ja auf den usb stick machen.
was, man kann die geforce experience ausmachen? wirklich, das glaube ich net.
vor allem, ich kann jetzt einfach mal das setup auch gar nicht abbrechen.
das mit maus lag, das killt mich.
jetzt starten wirs von hier.
ich will jetzt nur den grafikkarten treibern und dann kann ichs hoffentlich ohne maus lag verwenden.
weil dann ein camlink ordentlich funktioniert. ja ja, run.
das hatten wir doch schon.
ja dann extracte halt noch mal. wenn du willst, extracte noch mal.
der.net installer läuft noch, der kann meinetwegen auch laufen, soviel er will.
ich mach auch nicht die express install, ich mach jetzt die, oh ne jetzt checkt er wieder.
oh ho, high, high speed.
ok advanced, advanced.
ey das mit dem maus lags ist echt nicht normal.
ah guck mal, guck mal, guck mal.
jetzt braucht er den müll nicht mehr.
das ist ne oller dualcore zeleron worauf das installiert wird.
was bitte ist enview, was weiß ich, envidia hat doch alles mit n, n irgendwas genannt.
ja ja mach, continue, continue.
stop installation, war der kram nicht richtig gesigned oder was?
oh man, also geschwind war es auch nicht.
ich installier erstmal kein.net, ich installier erstmal den grafikkartentreiber.
und dann hoffe ich, dass camlink geht und ich ohne maus lag den kram verwenden kann.
dann installieren wir uns in browser.
glaub ich schick den camlink echt wieder zurück wenn das so rumspackt.
restart now, jawoll gibs mir.
opera gaming browser, läuft der unter xp?
der opera gaming browser?
kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
das ist doch auch nur ein chrome.
oh ja leute, richtig echter poggers fullscreen.
fullscreeniger fullscreen.
ok, leute jetzt probier ich nochmal den, jetzt probier ich nochmal den passthrough zum camlink.
ob der jetzt immer noch der meinung ist das hdcp oder ob der das jetzt irgendwie gecheckt hat.
wo hab ich den camlink jetzt hin?
oh leute ich hab hier so übertrieben viele kabel rumliegen ich weiß nicht wo hab ich den camlink hin.
hier zu viel zeug was hier rumliegt.
so, auf gehts ran.
so, detectchamp auf elgato erkennen please.
detectchamp auf...
ja ich versteh, der passthrough sollte eigentlich genau das machen, passthroughen.
was aber keinen sinn ergibt, dass der passthrough, also ohne passthrough direkt am camlink geht und andersrum nicht.
monka, giga, was ist hier los?
das könnte jetzt an der captcha software liegen.
wow, ah jetzt ist es wieder grün.
ok, also seh ich das richtig, wir haben die auswahl zwischen flimmern oder grün.
das e-port ist garantiert nicht kaputt.
ok leute, passt mal auf, passt mal auf.
jetzt hab ich direkt angeschlossen, geht sofort. eigentlich total der witz.
was hat der mit dem passthrough für probleme?
ok jetzt wirds nochmal spannend, jetzt müssen wir uns firefox 25 runterladen über, da brauch ich die tastatur.
ich nehm mal den internet explorer, na da, viel spaß.
aber mal gucken ob google geht.
ja ja jetzt ist gut, der lag an der captcha karte.
google hat noch http für so alten kram, firefox 25 esr war das glaub ich für windows xp.
fdp, ok fuck, moment das ist https, https kann immer funktionieren.
fdp, ok, hat der mal nen direkt klingel oder so, zu advanced, chip easy, ah fuck.
ja wo komm ich mit internet explorer 6 noch drauf?
ich hab ne idee, ich hab ne idee, moment einfach nur ftp.
konnte das ding ftp? ne das mit einfach nur http funktioniert nicht.
hab ich schon ausprobiert eben.
ja ich wollte es jetzt über die e6 machen, ich hab den rest schon über den usb stick gemacht.
das ist ja doof.
ne der windows explorer, das ist ja unter der haube.
der lehnt mit http runter, ernsthaft? aber ich kann da nicht drauf?
ich machs jetzt, ich, leute ich mach.
null, einfach, einfach was gecrashed wieder.
ok ich machs auf den usb stick.
ich muss gar nicht rüber kopieren, den mach ich jetzt schnell mal auf den usb stick.
ich glaub anders kriegen wir das jetzt nicht gebacken.
so also, nein nein das ging nicht, ich hab's doch gesehen, ging nicht.
das geht im modernen browser vielleicht, aber im ee-dings ging's nicht.
also windows 32, us, da ist es.
naja, auf.
firefox setup, ee-doppelpunkt, hopp, sehr gut, haben wir's doch schon, geht doch viel besser.
geht doch viel besser im usb stick.
so, sehr schön.
wo haben wir einen firefox, da ist er, nice.
ich bin begeistert, das sieht ein bisschen pleich aus das bild.
bam, da ist er, leute, da ist er.
der richtig echte firefox, aber leider schon die version mit dem kackmenü.
also jetzt können wir auch mal ordentlich hier drum rumklicken.
also kann ich euch mal zeigen was da drin ist, da ist wirklich, die hardware ist nicht, nicht, sondern nicht gut.
aber dual port netzwerk, dual port netzwerk und wlan, hat er, ee, ne festplane mit glaub 500g, war das hier irgendwo?
500g, 60gb natürlich, 500 wäre viel zu groß gewesen, ne?
im system kann ich kein, kann ich kein crisis spielen oder?
also das demo, also wie warm wird das ding eigentlich, sieht man hier irgendwo die temps?
also das ding ist schon ganz schön warm.
also fühlt sich wärmer an, ich habe die hand neben halde.
ok, wir downloaden jetzt die crisis demo, leute.
von 4 players haben wir die letztens geladen oder?
gif, crisis demo
ja ja, download, please, einfach downloaden, crisis sp demo, exellent.
ok, wait, ah ne es geht schneller, hat ein bisschen gedauert, hat ein bisschen gedauert, 8 min, 8 min kann ich mit leben.
ok, ok, ok, ok, ok.
allerdings jetzt mal die richtige zeitzone einstellen, wo wir gerade dabei sind.
im t plus 1, 2 hier, wo ist denn berlin da?
genau, das waren die tschechentreiber, die nicht funktioniert haben, ne?
wer weiß, vielleicht sind die treiber vom russischen geheimdienst.
alle schon am start hier.
alle kommen jetzt schon bei mir auf der büchse drauf.
leute crisis läuft da drauf nicht gescheit, das ist ein dualcore zeleron, 1,1 gigahertz, 2g ram, ne gt 610.
das läuft mit 5 fps.
wir werden es gleich sehen, wenn 4player sich jetzt mal ein bisschen beeilt.
gt 610 war doch damals der shit, nein, gt 610 ist das die unterste ende des unteren endes.
wie ist der ram verbrauch? sieht man das schon im task manager? ne.
wo sah man das in diesem alten task manager hier, oder?
ne. sieht man hier den ram usage?
ach hier, das wurde in k natürlich, sodass man es nicht versteht. da sind sogar 4g ram drinnen. und er kann 3,6 adressieren, obwohl es ein 32g system ist. was ist denn da los?
ist denn nur mit kasten los?
by the way wollen wir mal gucken wie gut youtube läuft, native.
oh, funktioniert das gut. stell euch mal vor es gibt noch omas auf dieser welt, die genau so sich jeden tag florian silbereisen auf youtube angucken.
der captures gar kein audio, oder?
was hat der für einen standard audio zeug? eigentlich sollten wir sounds hören.
jetzt nicht skippbar. naja, ich mein, mein aktuelles video braucht auf 480p 100% cpu last. da kann man sich nicht beschweren würde ich sagen.
480p 100% cpu last kann man schon mal machen denke ich.
720p wie siehts damit aus?
oh ne ne ne ne da geht nicht mehr.
ey das ding das kühlt mir auch gleich durch den bildschirm durch.
aber warum haben wir keinen sound? den sound ausgeschaltet hier?
wir sollten eigentlich sound haben.
das muss, ah hier unten. excellent.
wobei ich gar nicht weiß, läuft windows 10 auf 32? ne moment, ne das ist ja schon eine 64bit cpu das funktioniert klar.
so jetzt können wir uns gleich crisis in 5 fps angucken.
windows startup sound ok ok weil ihr seid leute.
was cancel cancel.
exit windows und und und start windows.
der sound.
klingt ein bisschen wie diese, wie diese komische katze.
diese cat ich weiß gar nicht wie dieses meme heißt. wisst ihr was ich meine? diese katze diese popcat ja genau.
das popcat. ok crisis runtergeladen easy. auf gehts.
und run.
gib alles. extracte was das zeug stellt. extracte als gibts kein morgen mehr.
das ich hab grad keine vorschau weil ich grad nicht in chat klicken kann weil ich beide mäuse im einsatz hab. die vor dem rechner und die andere maus hier dran.
wir spielen crisis durch mit 2 fps klar speedrun. crisis low spec speedrun.
ich wundere wenn es so eine komische kategorie sogar gibt. easy easy.
low fps prozent ja.
ok preisfrage was meint ihr wie das läuft leute. aber 3 sachen zur auswahl komplett unspielbar. spielbar aber nicht gerade angenehm oder gut spielbar.
oder startet erst überhaupt nicht. die 4 sachen haben wir. predictions genau.
wir dürfen nicht vergessen der rechner das ding hier ist von 2012. crisis von 2007. das ist zwar low low low end spec aber das game war damals schon 5 jahr alt.
auf
style dicks noch ok finish finish easy easy.
startet das jetzt automatisch ne
spiel gato come on
please
was
jetzt ernsthaft
trash trash
das fand ich an diesem black magic zeugs wirklich gut. man muss ja sagen die haben jeden kack unterstützt was es so input mäßig gab.
mein problem ist jetzt wie sage ich crisis dass er nicht auf 1024 760 starten soll.
da fällt mir jetzt gar nichts zu ein ehrlich gesagt.
hallo gato ist es nicht supported ok jetzt habe ich echt ein problem.
ich dónde habe ich die
Das ist so trash, das Ding, das ist so trash.
Massive trash.
Einfach nur.
Aber das Ding erkennt es jetzt, oder?
Was ist passiert?
das ist 16k nicht nur 8k 8k ist 8k war gestern ok wie ich muss jetzt schnell auf yes kommen
jawoll excellent ok leute wie starten wir das irgendjemand hat auch gerade die optionen
geschrieben im im chat wie man was man angeben musste ok plus er wird gleich 20 plus er heißt
gleich 1080 so oder geht das jetzt haben wir mal
habe es auch wieder mit leck ha
nice gut da kann ich jetzt ja da kann ich jetzt in den trash link in den trash link umstöpseln
weil mit leck kann ich ja nicht mal das hauptmenü starten
eigentlich sollte mein trash link erkennen
warum erkennt er den nicht oder braucht er einfach nur dafür
jetzt die italien trash link ok nice crisis man kann den ganzen kram nicht überspringen
wo ist mein lautstärke knopf der lautstärke knopf ist einfach weg
aber was jetzt mit meiner maus was ich alle was
ja wie kann man jetzt fps gibt es in fps overlay in dem ding konnte man in game irgendwie
crisis fps anzeigen lassen das windows l in aus l locked in screen fraps ornee fraps kommt mir da nicht drauf
aber sehen ja gleich ob spielbar ist oder nicht er display info eins auch in die auch in die in den
start also auch in die verknüpfung rein das hat eine konsole so schon mal nicht
oh es ruckelt es ruckelt 14,6 fps
und es ist im flugzeug das wird gleich noch schlimmer leute es wird gleich noch schlimmer im
flugzeug läuft es gut im flugzeug ich sag euch im flugzeug läuft es noch gut sobald die tür
aufgeht ist vorbei ja ich mach gleich 720p ich will noch ich will noch warten ich will
noch warten bis wir aus dem flugzeug springen leise machen die tür geht auf leute die tür geht auf
jetzt ist vorbei jetzt ist vorbei
ja ja 15 ok moment options game settings also blut blut muss auf jeden fall auch
eine blutkehre kann man schon mal ein spiel yes so jetzt mal graphic details runterschalten
options quatsch nicht game settings alter game please option system settings graphics medium
ha ha ha lull wie low und video mode tausend dass da apply trash link trash link was ist
scheiß hardware alter mega trash huge trash link alter was ein krab richtig krasser trash
der kram meint ihr das ernst dass es jedes mal abkackt auch mal da ist es wieder
warum nimmst du den trash link wenn man andere capture card leckert
ist das schlecht das ist so das ist so schlecht alter so schlecht ich habe ich weiß nicht ob ich
ob ich da jetzt bock habtest ich will aber wissen mit wie viel fps das läuft ohne miss
das interessiert mich echt deswegen starte ich jetzt noch mal neu stöpselt es um und das ist
egal da machen wir das jetzt in der mit mit der leggy elgator das ist egal also mit der alten
wisst ihr was ich könnte auch einfach moment wo ist mein usb kabel oder ich blick gerade immer
durch mit den ganzen kabels hier ich könnte mir auch einfach eine neue elgator capture card
kaufen anstatt diesem komischen trash link weil die funktioniert wahrscheinlich und leckt auch
nicht also ich hatte mal ursprünglich eine black magic intenso pro oder wie das ding hieß damit
als ich auf youtube angefangen habe und das ding war echt gut für das also was es konnte konnte
ist wirklich gut da ging einfach alles ja das einzige problem war dass das keine 1080p konnte
30 fps und geschweige denn 60 sondern deswegen habe ich mir damals damals hatte ein bisschen
auch mit elgator rumgestellt so sponsor mäßig und da habe ich gesagt ok dann aber jetzt elgator
anspringen mit elgator anstatt so da war jetzt hier nämlich 720 1280
der sollte jetzt eigentlich checken du kannst das du kannst ein pc damit aufnehmen wenn das ist nicht
die ganze zeit krascht der trash link darf ich jetzt überspringen darf ich jetzt überspringen
ich habe es mir schon alles angeguckt ey lass mich überspringen cry attack please please
peggy 18 16 matter major nee mature mature heißt pogas englisch we are all sitting in
one boat auf geht's crisis hat bestimmt window mode ok hat es jetzt mal hat es jetzt gecheckt
hat es jetzt gecheckt dass ich system settings gemacht habe und graphics advanced auf low ja
objects quality kann man nicht auf flow machen single player load also konsole er ich habe
ich kann es jetzt halt nicht spielen weil ich habe leck ich habe ich habe ich habe zwei sekunden
eine halb bis zwei sekunden input leck damit ist es nicht spielbar aber ich kann gucken wie
die fps jetzt sind klar 990 fps pogas leute 990 fps huge sogar 99.999 also wir haben quasi
aufgerundet 1000 fps noch noch sind schon nur 252 und wenn wir glück haben press any key
einfach glück haben die 85 fps equate aber wenn das ist das intro das wird es wird es
gibt also auf low und 720p ist das so was so was wie spielbar aber wartet mal bis die
tür aufgeht ja es geht doch es sieht halt scheiße aus in in 1000 8 in low graphics ok
wenn wir gerade dabei sind wenn das so gut läuft aber medium graphics medium graphics
medium graphics
ich lasse ihn schwitzen ich aktiviere scale based matchmaking ich lasse ihn schwitzen
ich weiß nicht was die gpu temp sagt naja ok medium settings 720p ist spielbar ich meine
es ist zwar nicht schön ich meine es ist zwar nicht aber das geht das also 30 fps das
kann man spielen besser als switch spiele ja wenn es ist spielbar sind harte drops bei
ja das ist wahrscheinlich auch wenn er nachlädt von der festplatte aber das ist ohne scheiß
noch das geht das kann man spielen nicht dass man ist nicht dass man es wirklich machen
will aber es geht ist schon ok also es ist es ist ohne miss es wäre es wäre es wäre
spielbar muss auch ich muss auch die schildkröte bashen ich habe aber lag ich kann die schild
kröte nicht hinten weil ich maus lag hab die konnte man doch jetzt aufnehmen pick up
schildkröte dead ok leute genug reicht mir für heute genug windows xp war anstrengend
genug und der trash link der kommt zurück so ein crap alter trash link wird instant zurückgeschickt
complete trash einfach doch komplett trash das hört sich jetzt fast an wie xqc a trash
so ganze crap hier weg machen leute das stream war anstrengend wie lange habe ich jetzt gebraucht
4 und halb stunden um xp zu inszenieren crisis drauf zu starten hat ernsthaft windows ist
ja auch ganz schön fehlen der fragt mich ob ich ob ich laufwerk g fixen will und laufwerk
g ist nicht mal mehr etatscht jetzt nicht mal mehr ok ich brauche einmal das outro anstrengende
sache heute
anstrengende sache chat ich scroll noch mal kurz drüber irgendwas übersehen hab minecraft
aber jetzt nicht ich bin mal ich bin echt am überlegen ob ich das auf echter hardware
zeige oder nicht das ist pains richtiger pains champ also du kannst mit der 4k 60 pro das
eigenes signal vom pc aufnehmen ja kannst du machen ist ja kein unterschied vom input
ist der frasier am start
glaube ich habe nichts übersehen im chat was das muss man auf den scheiß knoben machen
das ist eine gute idee das ist nice aber nachdem ich kein knoben verwende
so ich glaube ich habe jetzt alles gesehen im chat da war mal ich bin gerade bei der dotnet
installation im chat das ist schon eine ganze weile her ja chat wenn ihr noch irgendwas
wissen wollt halt rauch haut raus ansonsten gehe ich jetzt abends ich hab hunger mein
persönliches highlight war das capture auf der realtech seite wo man nicht erkannt hat
also 104 chats capturen ist so ein ding das habe ich euch vor einer weile schon mal angeguckt
da gibt es capture karts aber wie gesagt sind ziemlich teuer allerdings muss man sagen
dass die dass die große elgato karte glaube ich auch 144 herz aufnehmen kann
aber du kannst mit hoher refresh rate spielen und niedrigere aufzeichnen
naja gut das ist eigentlich auch relativ sinnlos weil auf der konsole ist mit 100 für
ein fett scherz enix und auf dem pc kann man mit shadow play aufnehmen aber ja ich
verstehe was du meinst aber ich glaube das ist gar nicht mal so so wichtig
was gibt es zuerst nicht weiß er nicht was kosten was kosten die die elgato capture 4k 60 pro heißt
das teil oder mk 2 was ist denn mk 2 mk mk 2 alles eine pc express karte was ist in der
unterschied von einer 40k pro versus hd 60 pro oder hd s die haben da noch bestimmt ok
wir gucken mal gucken uns mal kurz an was die für dinge haben also 180p das wird mir ja sogar
reichen hauptsache leckfrei ok 2061 mit 2061 p mit 60 machen nur die pc express dinger
oder oder ist das ein usb was sind es das für ein teil usb capture card oder was mit ssd
drin ach das ist mit ssd drin ok naja gut das ist glaube ich nicht so nicht so geil oder
oder kann man die auch per usb anschließen und damit verwenden also wichtig dass es
keine input verzögern hat instant game reviewer das brauche sisse nope nope nope nope keine
latency das gibt es bei mir nicht mehr mit das das mache ich nicht mehr also im prinzip
gibt es ja nur die sache entweder die das pc express den kaufen oder die hier was ist
der unterschied zwischen hd 60s und hd 60s plus hdr 10 wer braucht denn sowas eigentlich
im prinzip gar kein unterschied so wirklich ne xp geht ja
meinst du das liegt wirklich daran dass es usb ist flon ich meine die normale hd 60 die
geht ja hast ja gesehen was was probleme macht ist da ist der trash link was hat eigentlich
black magic gerade zeig mal haben die irgendwas was mithalten kann mittlerweile mit auflösungen
und auch so zumindest nicht was 50.000 euro kostet wo ist denn ihr capture capture ist
der nachfolger von der ich habe oder ob ist die so günstig ob ist die so so in anführungsstrichen
günstig kann die den cap schon 808 p 60 ok hätte sie damals gegeben hätte ich mir direkt
eine gekauft ich hatte ja den vorgänger davon und die hat im endeffekt mit abstand die wenigsten
probleme gemacht die hat auch quasi jeden krabb gecaptured in zugabe
na gut leute also schön dass ihr am start gewesen seid ich gehe jetzt was essen ich
habe übelsthunger macht es gut wir sehen uns wahrscheinlich nicht morgen aber die tage
auf jeden fall bis der nco